COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND A
TEAR TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS NORMAL PRACTICES TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMITTED
PUBLIC MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TWO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW THEY WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE REVIEWS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR FOUR ZERO AGAIN.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE
SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ZERO. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE SEVEN
TWO. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN AGAIN
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE SEVEN
TWO. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. UNTIL YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE A
MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE. THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
CUSICK FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIAN AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WAS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
ARE HAVE THE CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
TO ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. ON
TODAY'S AGENDA WE HAVE THIRTEEN
BILLS. THERE ARE FIVE BILLS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH WE
WILL VOTE ON AT THE END OF THE
HEARING AND THOSE ARE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY THREE BY SOME MEMBERS
AARON. I DON'T FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT EIGHTY SIX NINETEEN BY
SOME MEMBER TODD AROUND. FILE
ITEM NUMBER. NINE EIGHTY SIX
SIX SIX BY SOME MEMBER TO. I AM
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
NINE BY SUMMER BELOW. AND FILE
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY TEN
FIFTY ONE BY SOME MEMBER
BENNETT. THE BILLS- JALEBI
HEARD IN FILE ORDER HOWEVER THE
ORDER MAY BE MODIFIED BECAUSE
OF THE VEIL ABILITY OF BILL
AUTHORS TO PRESENT AND THE NEED
TO COMPLETE THE HEARING AGENDA
IN A TIMELY MANNER. AND BEFORE
YOU HEAR PRESENTATION OF BILS-
WE WILL. ACTUALLY WE WILL BEGIN
FIRST AS A SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL
WE HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS HERE
PRESENT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM-
FOR BILL TESTIMONY DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. HIGHS THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR ONCE A TWO TIME LIMITS ON
BILL TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL
BE PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION I WILL
PERMIT UP TO TWO WITNESSES FOR
TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS OR A
MAXIMUM OF FOUR MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR NAME IS
FILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. YOU WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THOUGH TO ACTUALLY
ENTER YOUR POSITION ALSO ON OUR
WEBSITE- TO FIND MORE
INFORMATION. I DO HOPE TO HEAR
FROM EVERYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY HOWEVER BECAUSE WE HAVE
A DEFINITE TIME. AND TIME FOR
THE HEARING I MILLET I MAY
LIMIT THE TOTAL TIME FOR ALL
COMMENTS ON THE BILL. TO ENSURE
THE COMMITTEE'S ABLE TO
COMPLETE OUR HEARING AGENDA
TODAY. EVERYONE ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT TESTIMONY
ON ANY BILL BEING HEARD TODAY
ON THE HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE
THEY NOTED. SO WITH THAT YOU
CAN WE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE IS MORE MEMBERS
COME IN AND SEE DO WE HAVE ANY
AUTHORS AAILABLE AT THIS TIME.
YES  SEE A SEVEN MEMBER
REAVIS- ROBBERY RATES- I
BELIEVE YOU'RE GONNA BE
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY SEVENTY THREE IS THAT
CORRECT. SIR OKAY WELL THANK
YOU- PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU
WELL THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR-
AND SENATORS AGREE TO SEE%
EVERYBODY'S UP AND WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
OTHER ENGAGEMENTS AND AS A- THE
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL AND-
AS WE ALL KNOW- MISTER CHAIR-
YOU'LL WILDFIRES HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN A PART OF LIFE HERE. IN
OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW AS- OUR STATE BRACES FOR
THE POSSIBILITY OF ANOTHER- A
DEVASTATING FIRE SEASON NO
RECENT WILDFIRES AS TO SIX HAVE
BEEN STAGGERING- A RECENTLY
PUBLISHED A WILDFIRE SMOKE
STUDY FOUND THAT TINY PARTICLES
RELEASED IN WILDFIRE SMOKE OR
UP TO TEN TIMES. MORE HARMFUL
TO HUMANS. ARTICLES RELEASE
FROM OTHER SOURCES SUCH AS CAR
EXHAUST FACTORIES OR- OUR
PLANTS YOU KNOW IT DOESN'T TAKE
MUCH TO REMEMBER THE WILDFIRE
CONDITIONS FROM LAST YEAR AND
FROM PRIOR YEARS WHEN SKIES
WERE ORANGE THE AIR WAS FILLED
WITH TXIC LEVELS OF SMOKE. AND
CALIFORNIANS WELL WE WERE
ADVISED TO STAY INDOORS TO
AVOID OUTDOOR ACTIVITY. AND
WHILE MANY OF US HAVE THE
LUXURY TO SHELTER INDOORS OUR
FARM AND AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
REMAIN OUTDOORS AND SMOKY
FIELDS IN ORCHARDS. TO PICK
CROPS THAT HELP FEED CALIFORNIA
AND OUR COUNTRY. SO THIS
LEGISLATION SENATE BILL SEVENTY
THREE SIX TO BUILD ON CAL OR
OSHA'S STANDARDS FOR PROTECTING
FARMING AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
FROM WILDFIRE SMOKE AN
UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY
CONDITIONS. UNFORTUNATELY
DESPITE HAVING THIS FIRST IN
THE NATION EMERGENCY WILDFIRE
SMOKE STANDARD. MANY FARMING
AGRICULTURE WORKERS DIDN'T GET
TO THE WORKPLACE PROTECTION
THEY NEEDED LAST YEAR. YOU KNOW
THE COMBINATION OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AN UNPRECEDENTED
NUMBER OF WILDFIRES. THEY PUT
AN ENORMOUS STRAIN ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF PPP AND MADE IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO PROCURE
SUFFICIENT QUANTITIES OF THE
RECOMMENDED N. NINETY FIVE
MASKS FOR. WORKERS AND FOR THE
WORK FORCE. SO THIS LEGISLATION
PROPOSES TO FIRST ENSURE THAT
THE STATE STOCKPILE OF N.
NINETY FIVE MASK WILL BE
UTILIZING MADE AVAILABLE. TO
OUR FARM NEGLIGENT WORKERS IT
WOULD- INSURE THAT WE DIRECTED
THE FORMATION IN AND OUT OF
DEPLOYMENT OF CAL OSHA WILDFIRE
RESPONSE STRIKE TEAMS DURING
MAJOR UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY
EVENTS. AND FINALLY WOODCOCK
TELLS YOU TO- TO WORK ON- THAT
PROVIDE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
WILDFIRE SMOKE SAFETY EDUCATION
MATERIALS AND TRAINING FOR ALL
PHARMACOLOGIC WORKERS YOU KNOW
THE NUMBER OF UNHEALTHY AIR
QUALITY DAYS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE ANNUALLY HERE IN OUR
STATE- AND I SHOULD NOTE IN OUR
FIRST IN THE NATION.
AGRICULTURAL STATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE CAN'T STAND FOR A
FORMER AGRICULTURE WORKERS TO
RESTORE HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
EVERY TIME THEY GO INTO THE
FIELDS TO HARVEST THE FOOD THAT
WE ALL NEED TO RESPECT US WHEN
I VOTE. AND MISTER CHAIR- WELL
WE DO HAVE TO THAT. WILL BE.
PROVIDES INTO. MARCO LEASE OUT
GOT FOR IT IS EXECUTOR OF A
LOCK. COOPERATIVA CAMPESINA THE
CALIFORNIA AND HER NINE
HERNANDEZ- HAVE NOT HERNANDEZ
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA FORMER DEFENDER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SYSTEM MEMORY LISTS- FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WILL NOW MOVE TO
TESTIMONY SUPPORT WILL BEGIN
WITH MARCO LITTLE. THAT'S RIGHT
YEAH HE WAS UP IN THE GALLERY-
YOU HAVE- TWO MINUTES- IF YOU
GO OVER THE TWO MINUTES OF THE
TWO MINUTE WARNING THAT COMES
OUT THE TIME OF THE SECOND
WITNESS SO JUST KEEP THAT IN
MIND- WELCOME PLEASE BEGIN.
FEDERAL RECORD RICHARD HERRING.
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH. WE LIVE IN
A STATE. WHERE WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATED EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND FARMWORKERS. ANYWHERE
MAYBE MORE THAN HALF OF THESE
ARE UNDOCUMENTED. IT IS A
POPULATION THAT DURING THE CALL
THE DEFENDER MADE WAS HEAVILY
EXPOSED TO THE VIRUS. WHILE
MAINTAINING OUR FOOD SUPPLY.
THEY WERE NOT JUST A SENSUAL
LABOR FORCE. THEY'RE ALMOST
BECAME A SACRIFICIAL LABOR
FORCE. TODAY WE LIVE IN THE
HISTORICAL PERIOD WHERE WE ARE
EXPERIENCING AN EXPONENTIAL
INCREASE. IN WILDFIRE FREQUENCY
AND INTENSITY CAUSING DAMAGES
ON THE MAGNITUDE NOT. SEEN
BEFORE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT HAS BEEN
REFERRED FOR USE THAT YOU
RETURN QUALITY. THE ONE CENTURY
FIRE EVER WAS SEVEN POINT THREE
FIVE PER YEAR. BUT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ALONE THEY
HAD SIXTY NINE FIRES. THE FARM
WORKERS FACE A SITUATION TODAY
WHERE THE WILDFIRE SMOKE
INHALATION IS INEVITABLE. WHEN
THEY HAVE TO CONTINUE WORKING
AND BEING EXPOSED. TO HEAVY
SMOKE WITHOUT ADEQUATE
PROTECTION. THIS IS BRINGING A
GREATER NUMBER OF HEALTH RISKS
FOR FARMERS THE CHEMICALS FOUND
SMOKE GET THE POSITIVE IN THE
SOIL AND BOLSTERING THE WATER.
THE INSTALLATION OF MOKE MAY
BRING ABOUT PULMONARY DISEASES
CARDIOVASCULAR ILLNESSES AT AN
EXACERBATIONS OF ASTHMA. BUT HE
BELIEVES THE RISKS INCLUDE
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS THAT MIGHT
BE CONTAINED IN THE EMISSION OF
ASH AND SOIL PARTICLES IT'S
DUST DURING AGRICULTURAL
ACTIVITIES. MAYBE SEVENTY THREE
OFFERS A SOLUTION TO THE
CONDITIONS SUFFERED BY FARM
DURING THESE WILDFIRES. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO PLEASE
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY THREE
SUBMITTED BY ASSEMBLYMAN ROBERT
REQUEST WITHIN. FIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
NOW MOVE ON TO- HERNANDEZ
HERNANDEZ- MODERATOR I BELIEVE-
MISTER HERNANDEZ FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKER
FOUNDATION SHOULD BE ON THE
LINE TO BRING HIM ON I THINK
THAT BRING MISTER AND ENDS ON
THE LINE. FOR HIS TESTIMONY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU.
I'VE BEEN HERE ABOUT MEMBERS OF
THE MODERNIZATION OF WILLIAMS
FORMER CO FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
OF LEGISLATION YOU FEEL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT
FARMWORKERS SPECIALLY DURING
THE WILDFIRES AND AS WE HAVE A
LOT OF SCOPE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC MORE THAN EVER. ON
RECORD THE PROTECTION AND WE
ARE IN TOTAL SUPPORT AND WE ASK
FOR AND I. CAN PROTECTED IN THE
UPCOMING WILDFIRE. SEASON AFTER
WORK THANKS THANK YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTING. WELL NOW IT'S TAKE A
QUICK FOR MOMENT ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
QUORUM. CAN HEAR AND HEAR
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S HERE ADMIN.
ADMIN HERE GONZALEZ GROVE. HERE
GROWTH HERE HER TADO. LEAVE AT
THE MOMENT ROCK YOUR BREATH
HERE RUBIO PRESIDENT RUBIO HERE
WINNER. OKAY CONTROL NOTES
THAT- WE HAVE A STEP A QUORUM
IS AT PRESENT AND HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED- SO NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY SEVENTY
THREE LOOKING UP AT THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SAYING NO WITNESSES AT
THE PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE
THROUGH IN TWENTY FORTY. AND
SOON FELT NO ONE AND NO ONE AT
THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON TO THE LINE
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY SEVENTY
THREE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MARK FENSTER MAKER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES AND
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE A LINK
FOR THE- TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION ARE THESE CONCERNS-
MICHAEL. MILLER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WINE
GRAPE GROWERS A MODERATOR
PLEASE- BRING ON- MICHAEL
MILLER- FOR HIS TESTIMONY AND-
YOU HAVE- BECAUSE THE OTHERS
THAT THE ENTRY HAD FOUR MINUTES
YOU HAVE A MAXIMO FOUR MINUTES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOUR
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS MICHAEL MILLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS AND THAT SUPPORT
AND NOTE THAT THE BILL DOES
HAVE NO OPPOSITION I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE WE ALL. AGREE WITH WHAT
THE BILL IS TRYING TO DO- WE'VE
BEEN VERY SUPPORT OF ALL OF
THE- INTEREST AND CONCERN AND A
GOAL OF GETTING- AND NINETY
FIVE MASK RESPIRATORS. FOR
EMPLOYEES IN WILDFIRE SMOKE
SITUATIONS- AND WE CAN CONTINUE
THAT LAST YEAR WE HAD A BIG
LESSON LEARNED WHEN THOSE MAPS
WERE UNAVAILABLE DUE TO COLD.
AND MISTY HAD TO READ THIS MASK
FROM THE ESTATE STOCKPILE AND
DISTRIBUTED THOSE TO THE
COUNTER WHAT SORT OF-
COMMISSIONS TO THE EMPLOYERS
YOU GOT THEM THEY HAD TO
REPLACE RIGHT AWAY AND THAT
THAT WORK VERY WELL. ON THAT WE
SUPPORT THE- THE AFTERNOON. I
WANT TO GIVE A STAFF OR-
PARAGRAPH ABOUT OTHER ARE NOT.
THAT PART OF THE BOTTOM OF PAGE-BY. A VERY VERY ACTUALLY CARE.
OUR CONCERNS THE DELL. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I'M JUST ONE
PARAGRAPH HIGHER PARAGRAPHS SIX
OF THE BOTTOM OF EACH FIVE. THE
SUPPORT AMENDED I THINK THAT
PARAGRAPH HIGHLIGHTS THE- THE
ISSUE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
OUT THERE SIMPLY SHOULD YOU
MEET A LOT OF CONFUSION ABOUT.
ALL THIS THIS- REGULATIONS
WORKS. THE CALIFORNIA
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS BOARD. APPROVED A
REGULATION FROM OPERATIONAL
PROTECTION. THE REGULATION
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO NOTIFY
AMAZON EMPLOYEES WHEN THERE'S A
WILDFIRE SMOKE SITUATION. AND
TO PROVIDE THEM N. NINETY FIVE
RESPIRATORS VOLUNTEER YEARS TO
PROTECT THEM FROM SMOKE
EXPOSURE. THAT REGULATIONS IN
EFFECT AS BEING FORCED BY CAL
OSHA. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT CONTINUES BECAUSE IT IS
WORKING- SO WE THE NUMBERS ARE
SUGGESTING ARE TO KEEP IT
CONSISTENT. WITH THAT
REGULATION. AFTER DECADES. WHAT
YOU MAY. A LITTLE WE- THE
BOARDS DOWN THAT IS APPROVED
AND THEN YOU HAVE A NEW LAW
COMING IN BEHIND IT YOU TRY TO.
YOU KNOW I'LL PROVIDE THE NEED
TO COMPLY WITH THAT STANDARD
THE BIG FADING AT VIRTUALLY
OTHER REQUIREMENTS CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH THAT STANDARD
SO. WHAT WAS ACTUALLY TRYING TO
GET AT IS LET'S MAKE IT
CONSISTENT WITH THAT STANDARD.
ABOUT HOW THE TRAINING WORKS A
MASTER PROVIDED AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE- THAT THE PROGRAM.
WORKS WITH THE GOAL OF GETTING
THE N. NINETY FIVE MASKS TO
EMPLOYEES. IS THAT PROGRAM IS-
GETS DOWN UNDER EXISTING LAW
HOW ALL WORKPLACE STANDARDS ARE
ADOPTED AND ENFORCED. AND THAT
SHOULD CONTINUE AND SOME SORT
OF MAKE SURE. THAT THAT THAT IS
NOT IMPORTANTLY- I'M DONE BY
THIS BILL AGAIN WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. YOU WORKING
WITH COMMITTEES ARE STAFFED
WITH THE OFFICE STAFF WILL
HAPPEN THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE THESE CONCERTS. AND
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF HIM TAKING
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND-
WITH THE PICTURES OFF THE
ABILITY WILL GET SUPPORT ON THE
BILL BECAUSE WE DO VERY MUCH
SUPPORT. THE BILLS TRYING TO DO
I THINK IT'S ON THE COMMITTEE
AND THE STAFF FOR YOUR TIME.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT SO
WE'LL NOW TAKE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTY THROUGH TO GET PUBLIC
GALLERY SINGLE PUBLIC GALLERY.
THE MICROPHONES MOVED THROUGH
IN TWENTY FORTY. C. KNOWN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- I. PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE. FOR WITNESS WHO WISH
TO. IN OP. TO EIGHTIES. THREE
NAME OR EXIT POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT FOR FIRST LINE
THANK YOU.
ONE ONE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICHARD
RIVERA I'M WITH SOCIAL EQUITY
LA AND- WE'D LIKE TO OPPOSE.
THE BILL AND THAT CEMENTED
THANK YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH-
NEXT LINE. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES NOT POSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
LET'S BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CENTER GROVE I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I DO HAVE A COME A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS THAT I'D LIKE TO
ASK THE AUTHOR. AND FIRST I
APPLIED YOUR BILL I THINK IT'S
REALLY GOOD THAT WE'RE GOING TO
USE EXISTING M. P. B. E. THAT'S
AVAILABLE IN A STOCKPILE. AND
TO PROTECT OUR FARM WORKERS WHO
BRING OUR FOOD TO THE TABLE AT
THE CENTER VALLEY IS BLESSED
TO. HAVE MANY FARM WORKERS AND
MANY PEOPLE THAT- PRODUCE FOOD
ACTUALLY OF BUT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHERE THE TOP THREE FOOD
PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE WORLD
SO- I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES ARE
STOCKED IN SHARES IN THAT. AND-
THAT BLESSING AS WELL. BUT WE
ALL REMEMBER I GUESS- WHEN
COLBERT STARTED THE BILLION
DOLLAR MASS DEAL- THE NATION
STATE TRYING TO FIGHT AND-
OTHER YOU KNOW ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA THE GOVERNOR WAS
ACTUALLY COMPETING WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT'S WHY HE
REFERENCED CALIFORNIA'S A
NATION STATE. WITH THE AMOUNT
OF THEM. B. E. THAT HE WOULD BE
ACQUIRING FROM DIFFERENT
NATIONS SPECIFICALLY I BELIEVE
CHINA- BUT- I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS IF WE HAVE TO STOCKPILE NOW
AND T IS AN IN IT AVAILABLE TO
US AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH OR WHEREVER
IT'S AT. AND WE HAVE A RISE IN
THE PANDEMIC AGAIN AND WE NEED
THESE N. NINETY FIVE MASKS FOR
FRONTLINE WORKERS LIKE NURSES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT- HOSPITALS
WHICH WE WERE STRUGGLING TO
GET. IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC FOR AT LEAST THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS. DOES YOUR BILL TAKE
IT DOWN TO ZERO AND DEPLETED TO
NOTHING OR DO WE LEAVE SOME
THERE JUST IN CASE WE HAVE A- A
RISE IN THE PANDEMIC AGAIN WE
NEED ACCESS TO THOSE TYPES OF.
THAT TYPE OF PP- OR- DO YOU
DOES YOUR BILL REFERENCE IT AND
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HAVE A
CHANCE TO READ THE WHOLE THING
MEASURES QUESTIONS THAT CAME UP
AS I READ THE ANALYSIS. YES SO
I- APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS IN
YOU KNOW ARE HAPPY TO- INSURE
THAT. WE PROVIDE SOME FOLLOW UP
BUT YOU KNOW CERTAINLY AS THE
BILL STIPULATES YOU KNOW.
REQUIRING THE CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH THESE THESE
THESE EXISTING AGENCIES THAT
HANDLE THE STOCKPILE- AND YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY HOPE THAT- YOU
KNOW WE CAN WORK TO. ENSURE
THAT WE CLARIFY THAT- THE
DEPARTMENT FOOD NAG BE INVOLVED
AS WELL- BUT BUT CERTAINLY IN
THE BILL IT DOES- TATING THAT.
THAT YOU KNOW RICKY- THE YELP
REVIEW. REQUIRING A REPORT
FROM. FROM- THE DEPARTMENT OF-
OF- STATE PUBLIC HEALTH WITHIN
SIX MONTHS OF THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF THIS BILL WITH REGARD
TO THE AMOUNT OF P. P. IN. THE
STOCKPILE. THE AMOUNT OF TV
FROM THE STOCKPILE THAT HAS
BEEN USED AND THE AMOUNT OF-
ANTICIPATED FUTURE USAGE- AND
YOU KNOW AND SO I WOULD- YOU
KNOW- BE HAPPY TO. DO SOME
FOLLOW UP TO MAKE SURE THAT-
YOU KNOW WE ADDRESS THE
SPECIFIC CONCERN. MA'AM
SENATOR. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT I GUESS YOU KNOW LIKE I
SAID I REALLY LIKE THE BILL I
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE STILL
WORKING THAT NEED- YOU KNOW
WHEN. YOU'RE IN A HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AREA OR THE SMOKE GOES
DOWN TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY FROM
THE NORTH. AND WE DO NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT EMPLOYEES ARE
PROTECTED I GUESS. MY CONCERN
WHICH  RELATE TO YOU IS- IN
THE HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC THAT
TERM WE WERE ALL SCRAMBLING TO
GET MASK AND- PP. F. FOR
EVERYONE AND SO I DO HAVE A
CONCERN THAT WOULD BE IT WOULD.
DEPLETE ZERO R. STOCKPILE. BUT
YOUR FOLLOW UP- ON THAT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL AND I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. MY SECOND.
QUESTION THAT I HAVE FOR YOU.
AND AN IS THAT ONCE WE- SEE
IT'S- I DON'T KNOW FIFTY PER. I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE NUMBER
IS BUT JUST SAY IT'S FIFTY
PERCENT. WHEN WE REACH THAT AND
THERE'S NO MORE THAN 50%
AVAILABLE IN THE STOCKPILE OR
WHATEVER NUMBER YOU DEAN. AND
SUITABLE FOR THE BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T GO BELOW
THAT IN THE STOCKPILE. AND IT
STILL REQUIRED BY LAW. IF IT'S
NOT IN YOUR BILL IF IT'S NOT-
PROVIDED FOR BY DEPARTMENT OF
IT AT C. P. H. THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. WHO PROVIDES
THAT IS A TEAM PLAYER THAT
WOULD PROVIDE IT AFTER THE
STOCKPILE IS DEPLETED TO A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE POINT OR-
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO BE
PROVIDED FOR THESE MASK AFTER
THAT STOCKPILE. IS DEPLETED
SURE SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS
ACCORDING TO THE CURRENT- STATE
STANDARD OF YOU KNOW WILDFIRE
SMOKE- STANDARD THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED. JUST PART OF THE
PANDEMIC. IT IS- THE EMPLOYER'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO- INSURE THAT
THEY ARE THAT. THEY ARE
PROVIDING THIS BP IN PARTICULAR
AND I FIVE MASTED PLAYERS AND
AS YOU STATED IN. A SENATOR YOU
KNOW THE ABILITY FOR THE
INDUSTRY TO. PROCURE THESE
MASKS WERE. IMPOSSIBLE AS THE-
THE AMOUNT OF CHARGES THAT ARE
STATED IN AN IN COUNTRY FACED.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND I DO
KNOW I MEAN I KNOW OF THE
FARMERS IN OUR AREA PROVIDE P.
PT PP TO THEIR PLAYERS AND IT'S
REQUIRED BY CAL OSHA. BUT WHEN
IT'S NOT AVAILABLE AT ALL I
MEAN THEY WERE SCRAMBLING
TRYING TO PROVIDE PP SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
FOURTH THOUGHT THAT YOU HAD AND
THINKING OUTSIDE OF THE BOX
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE THIS
MASSIVE STOCKPILE. AND THE ONLY
THING THAT I WOULD REALLY LIKE
YOU TO FOLLOW UP WITH ME AND I
THINK EVERYBODY I CAN'T SPEAK
FOR EVERYBODY BUT I WOULD THINK
IT WOULD BE ON EVERYBODY'S MIND
IS THAT. THAT WE- NOT DEPLETE
COMPLETELY THE STOCKPILE THAT
WE HAVE JUST IN CASE WE COME
INTO ANOTHER AND COOK IT
SITUATION AND THEN IN THE NEXT
YEAR TO YEAR SO IT WOULD BE
NICE TO HAVE THAT AVAILABLE- SO
THAT WE'RE NOT FRANTICALLY.
COMPLETING COMPETING WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES IN ORDER TO-
REPLENISH WHAT WE'VE USED. IN
THIS BILL- SO THANK YOU SIR
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME ASK
YOU THOSE QUESTIONS. AND THEY
HAVE A QUESTIONS BE SURE TO.
RIGHT UNDER THE OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE OF THE THIRTY FIRST
OF ALL- THANK YOU SO MUCH
SUMMER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD THAT SAY ALRIGHT I'M
I'M I PERHAPS GOING TO
PARTIALLY ADDRESS HOPEFULLY THE
QUESTIONS OF MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM BAKER STILL DOESN'T GROW.
UP BECAUSE AS THE AUTHOR WITH
US OUR LABOR OF THE ORIGINAL
STOCKPILE BUILD. IT DOWN HERE
IS THAT THE STOCKPILE OBVIOUSLY
IN A LARGE EVENT LIKE COVE IT
EVEN IN TRYING NEVER GOT WE'RE
TRYING TO BUILD A STOCKPILE
ENOUGH. TO AVOID THAT HOWEVER.
FOR THE PURPOSES HOUSE ACTUALLY
THE BUFFER IN TO BUY TIME RATES
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT.
IN AN IMMEDIATE CRUNCH OF
COURSE THERE'S VERY LITTLE PP
AVAILABLE SO PRICES GO SKY HIGH
IT'S AN ACCESSIBLE YOU KNOW
YOU'RE POTENTIALLY AT RISK
FROM- PREDATORY SELLERS WHO
EITHER DON'T CARRY THROUGH OUR-
SUPPLY SUBSTANDARD PRODUCT. SO
THE IDEA IS THAT THE STOCKPILES
THE SHARES AT LEAST FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME YOU DO HAVE
ACCESS TO. HIGHER COURT YOU
KNOW. TO THE DVD THAT IS. THAT
WAS PURCHASED AT WHEN THINGS
WORK TO ADDRESS SUCH A HIGH
PRICE ND SO FORTH AND- SO I
THAT'S HOW I VIEW THE STOCKPILE
HAPPENING. IS THE OBVIOUSLY IN
A LARGE PANDEMIC SITUATION IT
WOULD BUY SOME TIME ALLOWS YOU
TO RE ESTABLISH SUPPLIES CHAINS
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS BECAUSE OF
IT. I WOULD THINK THAT IN A
WILDFIRE SITUATION WHERE. THERE
MAY NOT BE A WORLDWIDE SHORTAGE
OR EVEN A NATIONWIDE SHORTAGE
OF PP WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS THE
STATE WOULD. MAKE THE STOCKPILE
OF SALEABLE- THE MAY MAKE
AVAILABLE AT COST- RIGHT SO
THAT'S A LOWER COST NOT EDDIE
YOU KNOW A CRUNCH CLASS. BUT
THEN ALSO OF COURSE AS SOON AS
WE'RE ABLE TO. SECURE
ADDITIONAL PP START PURCHASING
IT IN MASS TO RE- RESTOCK THE
STOCKPILES RIGHT. HOWEVER IF
IT'S IN A CRUNCH SITUATION AT
LEAST WE BOUGHT SOME TIME SO
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO CHASE DOWN
AND HAVING TO IMMEDIATELY BITE
BECAUSE OF THE IMMEDIATE NEED-
PP THAT IS EITHER UNAVALABLE
OR JUST SKY HIGH PRICES. RIGHT
SO THAT I THINK IS THE PURPOSE
OF THE STOCKPILE AND THAT
CERTAINLY WOULD I THINK HELP
EMPLOYERS BECAUSE IF THERE IS A
LOCAL SORT OF SHORTAGE. THEY'RE
NOT HAVING TO FIND IT AND THEN
HAVING TO BUY IT WHATEVER PRICE
I WAS WILLING TO SELL IT FOR
INSTEAD THEY CAN RELY ON THE
STOCK PILE INTO THE STOCK HOW
CAN BE IS A LARGE PURCHASER.
EVENTUALLY ABLE TO YOU KNOW-
REBUILT YOU KNOW BASICALLY
RESUME WHEN PRICES HAVE HAVE
SETTLED OBVIOUSLY WITH A VERY
LARGE OUTBREAK LIKE TELEVISION-
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A
CHALLENGE BUT- CERTAINLY I
THINK. THAT WE WHAT WE SAW WAS
THAT PEOPLE HAD EVEN HAD THE-
BE. SUPPLY LINES AND JUST I'LL
BE BUYS THE TO READ. SOME OF
THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS. AT THE TOP
YES SENATOR GROWTH. YOUR CHAIR
FOR ADDRESSING MY CONCERNS- I
DID I SAW IT HERE FROM THE
STATE LEVEL AS A LEGISLATOR AND
AS A BUSINESS OWNER. I ALSO SAW
IT- YOU KNOW JUST TRYING TO
OBTAIN PAPER MASK RIGHT. AND
YOU CAN GET IN FOR I DON'T KNOW
FIFTY CENTS EACH AND TILL.
COULD HAPPEN AND THEN THEY WERE
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO GET YOU
WERE PAYING FIVE DOLLARS A
PIECE. SO IT WAS AND THAT WAS
MY CONCERN IS IF WE DEPLETED
THIS BUT I APPRECIATE THE PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AND I THINK IT'S
A GREAT SOLUTION. TO A PROBLEM
THAT WE DO HAVE SO THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU BUT I GUESS THAT
ONE OTHER GUY I DID HAVE A
BRIEF QUESTION FOR YOU- SOME
THE NUMBER THAT THE- IT'S NOT
REALLY OPPOSITION BUT THE
CONCERN THAT WAS RAISED BY ALSO
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT THIS ILL
IS AFTER. A SIMILAR PASSES OUT
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD GO TO
LABOR WHERE I THINK THEY WOULD
PROBABLY MORE SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS THAT CONCERN BUT- DID
YOU WANT JUST ME BRIEFLY
RESPOND TO. THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE GREAT GROWERS IN TERMS
OF IS THERE ANY CONFLICT WITH
THIS BILL WITH EXISTING OSHA
GUIDELINES- REGARDING A P. T.
E. R. NO IN I- REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED AND WE HAVE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH- THE
ASSOCIATION AND WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO. AND WORK TO GET SOME
COMPROMISE LANGUAGE YOU KNOW WE
SHOULD- WE BE SUCCESSFUL THIS
AFTERNOON. OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT- OF WHICH
THERE'S. NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE-
REALLY. YOU KNOW- APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON AND RESPECT THAT FOR
FIVE OF THE SUBJECT OKAY. BASED
ON OUR ESTIMATE ISIS MOVED UP
OKAY THE MOTION THAT MOVE BY
CENTER EKMAN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS. TO THE COMMITTEE ON
SENATE LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
AND RETIREMENT COMMITTEE-
CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL PAN. HI CAN I MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I EGGMAN. EGGMAN
EIGEN SOLACE. GROVE HI GROVE I
HER TADO LISA HI LEAVE A I. LI
MON ROF FIVE ROTH IRA RUBIO
RUBIO I WINNER WINNER I. THE
BILLS CURRENTLY EIGHT ZERO HOLD
THE LINE CALL RIGHT LET'S NOW
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER ONE I SEE
SOME MEMBER AGRA CURRY HERE.
OKAY LET'S GIVE A MOMENT TO.
CLEAN UP THE PODIUM HERE. IT'S
A MOBILE MOVING OUT ITEM NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY FORTY FIVE BY SUMMER
I WOULD HURRY WELCOME. ELLO
WELCOME THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO ACCEPT AS AN AUTHOR'S
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY
ISSUE TWO ON PAGE. ELEVEN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DEALING WITH
THE CALCULATION OF THC IN HEMP
PRODUCTS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE. FOR ITS WORK ON
THIS MEASURE. MAYBE FORTY FIVE
CREATES A REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
FOR INDUSTRIAL HEMP PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN FOODS BEVERAGES
AND PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS. IT
LIMITS HIM PRODUCTS TO CONTAIN
NO MORE THAN THREE TENTHS OF A
PERCENT OF THC. REQUIRES THAT
HEMP PRODUCTS BE SUBJECT TO
TESTING AND LABELING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PRODUCTS.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
FEDERAL FARM BILL CLARIFIED
THAT INDUSTRIAL HEMP AS AN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT. AND
THE FEDERAL FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION SCHEDULES. THIS
ACTION CLASSIFIED HIM BEING
GREETED AS GENERALLY SAFE FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION. AND OPEN THE
DOORS FOR FARMERS TO CULTIVATE
CULTIVATE INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
CALIFORNIA LEGALIZED CANNABIS
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
NOTWITHSTANDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S POSITION THAT
CANNABIS IS ILLEGAL. IRONICALLY
WHILE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS REMOVED BARRIERS TO THE
LEGAL USE OF HEMP DERIVED
PRODUCTS INCLUDING CBD.
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT TAKEN A
SIMILAR APPROACH. CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY ALLOWS THE
MANUFACTURING AND SALE OF
RECREATIONAL MARIJUANA PRODUCTS
INCLUDING FOOD AND DRINKS YOU
DON'T WANT HIM IS THE SOURCE OF
CBD TO BE ADDED TO FOOD
PRODUCTS IT IS PROHIBITED. MANY
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN PERCHING HIM
DRIVE CBD PRODUCTS OF THEIR
LOCAL NATURAL FOOD SHOPS
FITNESS CENTERS AND EVEN HIGH
END DEPARTMENT STORES FOR SOME
TIME. THESE PRODUCTS ARE
UNREGULATED IN FACT SENIORS
HAVE PART A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF THE PEOPLE CHOOSING TO USE
HEMP CBD BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
WANT TO VISIT A MARIJUANA
DISPENSARY. THE MANUFACTURE AND
SALE OF CBD DERIVED FROM HEMP
IS RAPIDLY EXPANDING BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA. WITH MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC
PRODUCTIVITY. SHOULD THE CHANGE
SEES ME SHOULD THE STATE CHOOSE
NOT TO CLARIFY THAT HEMP CBD
PRODUCTS ARE ILLEGAL FOR SALE
IN CONCEPTION. BUSINESSES AND
THE TAX REVENUES ARE LOST. WE
SIMPLY HAVE A WILD WILD WEST
FOR CBD PRODUCTS NOW ONLINE AND
IN STORES AND WITH ONLY SELLING
ON REGULATED PRODUCTS. I DON'T
WANT MY CONSTITUENTS BUYING
UNTESTED UNREGULATED AND OUT OF
STATE FOR FOREIGN PRODUCTS. ARE
UNSAFE FOR FARMERS AND
BUSINESSES LOSE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY A. B. FORTY FIVE
WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
IT EASIER TO ACCESS THE NON
INTOXICATING ALTERNATIVE
PRODUCT CONSUMERS WANT. FOR
FARMERS TO ESTABLISH THEMSELVES
IN A FAST GROWING INDUSTRY.
WITH ME TODAY ARE TO TESTIFY OR
RANDOM MARTIN HERE IN THE
GALLERY REPRESENTING U. S. HEMP
ROUNDTABLE THAT EDDIE BERNACCHI
VIA PHONE REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA HIM COUNSEL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HIS ARM- AGARI-
SO NOW MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT SO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH- RAN MARTIN FROM THE U. S.
I HAVE BROWN TABLE AT THE
MICROPHONE AND THE GALLERY YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES TOTAL. FOUR
EARNING IT GOES OFF THE OTHER
PERSON'S TIME SO PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AGAIN RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE U. S. HEMP ROUNDTABLE VERY
QUICKLY TO SUMMARIZE WHAT THIS
BILL DOES AND WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT NUMBER ONE IT'S GOING
TO GIVE ACCESS TO MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO PURCHASE.
HIM CBD PRODUCTS- CURRENTLY
CAN'T LEGALLY- IT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO BUY SOMETHING THAT THEY
HAVE SOME COMFORT WITH RELATIVE
TO THE INGREDIENTS THAT THERE'S
NOT CONTAMINATION THINGS I
THAT. PROVIDES VERY CLEAR SO
THE CONSUMER SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS
TESTING- TO THE SAME LEVEL AS
CANNABIS AND NUMBER THREE IS
GOING TO JUMP START AN INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S GOING TO
BE A BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
NEXT TWO OR THREE YEARS. WITH
THOUSANDS OF JOBS BEING
CREATED. I WANT TO PICK THAT
REAL QUICKLY TO SOME OF THE
THINGS YOU'VE BEEN HEARING FROM
THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE VERY
CLEAR NUMBER ONE THE OPPOSITION
HAS SAID THEY'RE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
INCLUDE CANNABIS LICENSEES. WE
WANTED TO INCLUDE CANNABIS
LICENSEES JUST AS MUCH AS THEY
DO WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONVINCE THEM
THAT THAT'S A GOOD IDEA THAT WE
SHOULD BE- INCLUDING THAT
INDUSTRY AS WELL AND THEY CAN'T
INDUSTRY- WE THINK WE'RE GOING
TO GET THERE- BUT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A LITTLE
MORE TIME TO GET TERE. COULD
BE REALLY HELPFUL IF THE
OPPOSITION WOULD ACTUALLY BE
WORKING WITH US TO TRY AND GET
THE ADMINISTRATION TO AGREE TO
INCLUDE CANNABIS LICENSEES AND
THEY CAN'T- CAN'T SEE BEAUTY
SUPPLY CHAIN- THE OPPOSITION
TALKS ABOUT NEEDING TESTING
PARITY WITH CANNABIS. SO PAGE
FIFTEEN LINE NINETEEN OF THE
BILL SAYS TESTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR CONTAMINANT LEVELS SHALL BE
THE SAME AS THOSE FOR CAMPUS
I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH MORE
PARITY WE CAN GET IN THE BILL-
THAN. TO SAY THAT IT HAS TO BE
THE SAME AS CANNABIS. NUMBER
THREE- THEY WANT TO SEE PROBLEM.
ON NON MEDICAL CLAIMS THAT
CANNABIS HAS TO FOLLOW. THAT IS
IN THE BILL IS ALREADY REQUIRED
UNDER THE SHERMAN. FOOD DRUG
AND COSMETICS ACT. OF VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL TO WHAT'S IN THE
CANNABIS LAW. SO WE ARE
PROHIBITED FROM MAKING CLAIMS
IT CAN'T B SUBSTANTIATED.
THAT'S ALSO GOVERNED BY THE FDA
THE FDA IS CLAMPING DOWN WHERE
PEOPLE ARE MAKING.
UNSUBSTANTIATED MEDICAL CLAIMS.
I HOPE THOSE ANSWER THE KEY
QUESTIONS FROM THE OPPOSITION-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR VOTE ON
THIS BILL THIS IS VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL TO SB TWO THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH NOW LET'S
MOVE ON- MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE EDDIE
BERNACCHI FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HELP COUNSEL WHO'S GOING TO BE
DIVIDED DECISIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AND YOU HAVE A MINUTE
FIFTY FIVE SECONDS. COMPLAINTS
OPEN THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
BERNACCHI MAP THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL- WHICH IS A COALITION.
OF CALIFORNIA BASED HIM
CULTIVATORS PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS AND DISTRIBUTORS-
EIGHTY FORTY FIVE OF THE VITAL
MEASURE TO ENSURE THE CONTINUED
PROCESS OF THE INDUSTRY
CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW FOLLOWING
THE ISSUANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AT
THE QUEUE IN JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. WHICH
PROHIBITED THE USE OF PEPE
DERIVED CANNABINOIDS IN FOODS
AND BEVERAGES- OUR INDUSTRY OUR
EMERGENCY EMERGING INDUSTRY-
THE- SAUCER IS CHILLING EFFECT
ACROSS EVERY LEVEL PARTICULARLY
IN THE AREA OF CULTIVATION
WHICH LOST SIGNIFICANT OUTLET-
FOR THE BIO MASS. AB FORTY FIVE
RE AUTHORIZES THE USE OF HEMP
IN FOOD AND BEVERAGES AND
CANNED BEVERAGE PRODUCTS IN
DOING SO CREATE A SIGNIFICANT
PATH FORWARD FOR CALIFORNIA
FARMERS. TO EXPAND IN IN THE
INDUSTRY- IN ADDITION THE BILL
CREATES A REGULATORY STRUCTURE
PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS RELATED TO HEMP
DERIVED PRODUCTS INCLUDING
TESTING LABELING AND ENDURANCE
TO THE- SHERMAN ACT. AND
CURRENTGOOD MANUFACTURING
PRACTICES UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
THE ENCOUNTER WAS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ROBUST
CONSUMER PROTECTION PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL. AND SUPPORTS THE
AUTHORS- IMAGE TAKEN TODAY THAT
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CLARITY ON
THE CONFORMANCE WITH FEDERAL
LAW ON THE CAP OF TWO. POINT 3%
THC. IN HEMP INPUT VERSES THEY
HAVE RETAIL PRODUCT THEMSELVES
SO WITH THAT WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORT OF A. B. FORTY FIVE
AND- DR- THANK YOU. THANK VERY
MUCH. WE'LL NOW MOVE ON
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND SOME
UNDER THERE'S A CONSIDERABLE
PUBLIC INTEREST IN THIS SO-
OVER- GIVEN OUR AGENDA I'M
GOING TO BASICALLY SAY FOR
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY BOTH IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AFTER
THE MAIN TEST THE FIRES- WILL
CAP THAT AT FIFTEEN MINUTES-
SO- AGAIN IT'S NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY SO
BEGAN OF THE PUBLIC GALLERY.
RESTRAINING ONE WHICH SAYS FIND
A PUBLIC GALLERY IN SUPPORT.
OKAY NOPE WILL MOVE DURING
TWENTY FORTY SING ON ONE TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FORTY FIVE. NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I REMEMBER TELLING THE CANCER
WITH CORBIN CHARACTER ON BEHALF
OF CHARLOTTE'S WEB AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE ONE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN SENATOR CLINTON ARE
CLEAR WITH THE INTERNET BY
THIRTY BEHALF WITH THE KRONOS
GROUP AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES AND SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. OKAY THREE
ONE ELSE SORRY. I'M SORRY NO
OTHER LINE OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR NOW WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FORTY FIVE WE HAVE TO-
MAIN LEAD WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION- FIRST BEGIN WITH
MARVIN THE NATO AND UNITED
CANNABIS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION-
AND THEN WILL BE FOLLOWED BY.
WINS SILVER- FROM GETTING IT
RIGHT FROM THE START SO EACH OF
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU A TWO MINUTE WARNING
WHEN YET THE TWO MINUTES ALL
RIGHT SO WE'LL START WITH
MARTIN PINEDA. WELCOME. OKAY
OKAY HOLD ONE MINUTE DO WE HAVE
A THE MICROPHONE ON OKAY THIRTY
NINE THREE PLEASE AGAIN AGAIN
SORRY CENTER PANEL MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME AND
GIVE ME A TIME TO TESTIFY
SOMEWHERE INTERNET WITH
CALIFORNIA ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA USES UNITED
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION- ALONG
WITH THE LARGE REPRESENTATION
OF THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY IT'S A
OVER 75% OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AND OPPOSITION TO AB.
FORTY FIVE I WOULD HAVE IN A
POST ON THIS A MAN. AND HOW
MUCH TO THE- OF MR RAN MARTIN
SAYING THAT WE ARE SPEAKING.
THE BILL REQUIRES TESTING FOR
RAW MATERIALS WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR IS FINAL FORM IT'S NOT IN
THE BILL FINAL FOUR MEANING M.
F. ONCE THE PRODUCT IT'S
PACKAGED AND IT'S READY TO BE
CONSUMED BY AN INDIVIDUAL. ROB
PRODUCT AND IF YOU TEST IT IS
GOING TO GIVE YOU A VERY
DIFFERENT RESULT DAN WHEN YOU
HAVE A FINAL FORM CONTAMINANTS
METALS AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH HERE ALSO THERE
IS NO AGE THREE AGE LIMIT ON
THIS PRODUCT READ PASSING THAT
ON TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. WE SHOULD BE
DECIDING THAT THE NOT PUT AN
END TO THE STATE AGENCY WE
STAYED STRONG MEASURES TO
PROTECT OUR USERS AND THE
PUBLIC SO THAT'S MISSING ON THE
BILL- I LIKE TO JUMP ON IN.
THERE'S A WE ASKED FOR AND THEN
AND OF TEACHING TWO ZERO ONE
FIVE MILLIGRAM. WE HEARD THAT
THERE'S NOT. COMING WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT- WE THINK THAT
IT SHOULD BE LIMITED- THEN WE
HAVE A I TOOK SOME TESTING
PAIRED. THE OTHER. COMPONENT IS
ALLOWING THE CANNABIS-
MANUFACTURES CULTIVATORS
MANUFACTURERS RETAILERS TO BE
ABLE TO SELL THOSE PRODUCTS.
RIGHT NOW. THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IS ALREADY DECIMATED
SO THIS BILL REALLY CATERS TO
OUT OF STATE HELP.
MANUFACTURERS PRODUCTS COMING
FROM CHINA IN THE LIMITS JOBS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WHAT KIND
OF JOBS ARE CREATED IN
CALIFORNIA. MY WE ALSO ASK FOR-
CANNABIS ARE CONNECTED TO
MOVIES LISTED IN MILLIGRAMS
THREE TWO MINUTES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT TIME- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NOBLE.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR NOW MOVE
ON TO- DOCTOR LYNN SILVER WHO'S
ALSO GOING TESTIFYING FROM THE
GALLERY WELCOME. THANK YOU
SENATOR IS- MY NAME IS DR LYNN
SILVER I'M A PEDIATRICIAN
CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT UCSF AND
SENIOR ADVISER AT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE. A. B. FORTY
FIVE IS AN HISTORIC ERROR FOR
THE SIMPLEST OF REASONS. FOOD
IS FOOD TO BE SAFE FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN FOR
PREGNANT WOMEN AND BABIES IT
SHOULD NOT BE ADULTERATED.
ADDING NEUROLOGICALLY ACTIVE
CANNABINOIDS TO FOOD WITH KNOWN
SIDE EFFECTS AND DRUG
INTERACTIONS IS A VERY BAD IDEA.
A. B. FORTY FIVE UNDERMINES THE
OBLIGATION OF GOVERNMENT TO
ASSURE A SAFE AND UNADULTERATED
FOOD SUPPLY. THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE OF FDA REGULATION.
HAS BEEN THAT APPROVED
PHARMACEUTICALS CANNOT BE ADDED
TO FOOD OR SOLD THE SUPPLEMENTS
GET THIS BILL ALLOWS TO SUCH
SUBSTANCES CBD AND THC. INTO
FOOD SOLD AT THE CORNER STORE.
CBD ITSELF CAN CAUSE SOMNOLENCE
SEDATION DIARRHEA LIVER INJURY
AND INTERACTS WITH MANY
MEDICATIONS INCLUDING BLOOD
THINNERS. TWO MINUTES IS
INSUFFICIENT TO DESCRIBE ALL
THE WAYS THE SPECIAL INTEREST
pCURRENTLY SO POORLY DRAFTED
THAT IT ALLOWS THE TEACH YOU
PREVALENT OF EIGHTY FIVE
CANNABIS EDIBLES AND CANNABIS
AND BREWED BEER. EVEN WITH THE
PROPOSED CHANGES WHICH WE
HAVEN'T SEEN. THC EXPOSURE IS
NOT FULLY RESOLVED. THE SURGEON
GENERAL WARNS THAT EXPOSURE TO
CANNABIS IN UTERO DURING
CHILDHOOD AND ADOLESCENCE.
INTERFERES WITH BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT BUT WE DO NOT YET
FULLY KNOW. WHAT CANNABINOIDS
DRIVE THESE EFFECTS THAT HEMP
DIFFERS MOSTLY IN THC. ARE
THESE THE SNACKS YOU WANT YOUR
KIDS TO GRAB LUNCH BREAK. FOODS
SHOULD NOT REQUIRE LABEL SAYING
DON'T EAT UNLESS YOU ARE TWENTY
ONE. HOPE IT IS AN EMERGENCY
HEMP IS NOT. ITS REGULATION
REQUIRES ANALYSIS NOT URGENCY
THE BEST PATH IS TO AWAIT FDA
REGULATION. OR ALTERNATIVELY TO
AUTHORIZE C. PH TO PROPOSE A
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK. WITHIN
TWO TO THREE YEARS BUT A. B.
FORTY FIVE PM SCIENTIFIC
EVALUATION AND IS MORE HARMFUL
THAN HELPFUL- ALLOWING US TO
MEDICAL CLAIMS THAT SHOULD BE
ALLOWED FURTHERMORE PLEASE
INCLUDE TO CLOAK HEALTH
REGULATION IN SECRECY IS
DANGEROUS. MAYBE FORTY FIVE IS
DANGEROUS PLEASE PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN AND VOTE NO THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT- NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION- SAYING NO ONE
ELSE AT THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEN ON
ROUTE TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR.
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FORTY FIVE. AND AGAIN
IT'S NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY AND- SO PLEASE-
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. I THINK
YOU SHOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THEY'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT FOR FIRST LINE
THANK YOU.
TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JERRY HELLO PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED CAME WITH BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CANNABIS RETAILERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TWELVE OTHER PEOPLE
BIKING FRIENDS WRONG OPPOSITION
JV FORTY FIVE UNLESS AMENDED
WHAT ARE- AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE
GIVEN TO THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
NEXT LINE. NINE ONE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANTED YOU
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ACCORDING
TO POLICY DIRECTOR PROBABLE
CHARACTERS ALLIANCE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO MOST AMENDED THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NINE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I BRING A FENDER
BERKELEY PATIENTS GROUP WE ARE
OPPOSED TO MY COMMENDED. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NINE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY MAIN
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STEVEN
NAIL ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE L. B. C. EIGHT LONG
BEACH CANNABIS ASSOCIATION AND
WE ARE A HOLD ON THE COMMAND
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT LINE. KLEIN
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS OUR SIGNATURE SHOW
QUALITY RESEARCH ASSOCIATE AT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND
I AM STRONG OPPOSITION OF A
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU EXLINE.
NINE ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES PLEASE BEGIN
APART. HI MY NAME IS ADAM
JACKIE I'M CALLING FROM THE
LONG BEACH COLLECTIVE
ASSOCIATION AND- WE OF COURSE
ABOUT THE MATTER THANKS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANKS LINE. LINE
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LUIS
RIVERA FROM SOCIAL EQUITY LA
AND I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE AND
THAT CEMENTED ON P. B. FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. LINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JANET
RODRIGUEZ AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITING
COMMUNITIES FOR ACTIVE ALL
HEALTH POLICIES COALITION
COALITION WHICH IS A COALITION
AND ALLIE CONNIE ON THE
INTERSECTION OF TOBACCO
CANNABIS AND ALCOHOL POLICIES.
WHICH IS MADE UP OF MANY PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PREVENTION
PROFESSIONAL BLOODY COUNTY AND
WE ARE CLOSED ON LIFE AND ENDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE ONE OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOHNNY BELLA PLANE AND THE
PRESIDENT ATTEMPTED TO GO
CANNABIS RETAILERS ALLIANCE ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF MY NUMBERS WE
THINK THAT THAT WE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU EXLINE. FIND ONE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL
AND MICHAEL WONG WITH ANGELUS
CAMPBELL CO FOUNDER WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE UNTIL AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
USE HELLO MICHAEL JOHNSON- I
REMEMBER DOING THE COACHELLA
VALLEY CANNABIS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FAX LINE. THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH LET'S NOW BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBER CENTER WINNER.
pWINNER AS I MENTIONED TO THE
AUTHOR I SUPPORT. THIS BILL AS
I SUPPORTED THE SIMILAR BILL
AND SENATOR ALLEN. PRESENTED IN
THIS COMMITTEE EARLIER THIS
YEAR AND- THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO TACKLE- ASI
MENTIONED IT TO THE AUTHOR OF
THE ONE THING. I REQUESTED- TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH WITH
PARTICULAR THE SMALL- CANNABIS
MEDICAL CANNABIS EQUITY-
BUSINESSES IN PARTICULAR IN SAN
FRANCISCO- WE HAVE A VERY
ROBUST NETWORK OF THESE SMALL.
CANNABIS BUSINESSES INCLUDING-
MEDICAL CANNABIS AND WE'VE
WORKED VERY HARD- ON THE EQUITY
FRONT TO MAKE SURE THERE WERE-
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN MOST
IMPACTED. BY THE WAR ON DRUGS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
AND- AND- YOU KNOW BIT. USE
CANNABIS CAUSES OF COLOR ARE
ABLE TO- ARE ABLE TO SUCCEED.
AND IT'S BEEN VERY CHALLENGING
WITH LEGALIZATION. OF CANNABIS
AND SOME OF THE- FRANKLY
PROBLEMSWITH THAT BALLOT
MEASURE NOTHING'S PERFECT- THE
SORT OF BIT LARGER BUSINESSES
COME AND- AND CAN REALLY IMPACT
THE SMALL COMMUNITY BUSINESSES.
WE'VE WORKED REALLY HARD TO TRY
TO SHORE UP THESE BUSINESSES-
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE AND I'M
VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THEIR
CONCERNS. THAT THE LARGE LARGE
HEMP BUSINESSES COULD COME IN
AND POTENTIALLY BIG FIGHT- THE
SMALL LOCAL. CANNABIS
BUSINESSES AND IT'S A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT- FROZEN SALMON CISCO
I KNOW IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE. AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE- AUTHOR HAS
YOU KNOW INDICATED SHOULD
CONTINUE THIS WHOLE- TALK WITH
THEM AND TRY TO SEE WHAT CAN BE
DONE. IN THE BILL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE MAINTAINING- THAT
REALLY IMPORTANT BALANCE I'LL
BE SUPPORTING BOTH TODAY AND I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION. AND IF YOU
HAVE ANY. COMMENTS ON THAT I
WOULD. HAVE TO DO THE COMMENT I
HAVE IS THAT ABSOLUTELY I'M
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPONENTS. FROM OBVIOUSLY
NOT EVERY BILLS PERFECT BUT I
WOULD REALLY WANT TO MAKE IT
PERFECT SO WE HAVE TO COME BACK
AND DO THIS AGAIN. I THINK WE
WORKED REALLY HARD WITH THE
BOSS FIGHTS BUT I AGAIN I.
REALLY WANT TO HONOR PARTICULAR
SMALL. I'VE BEEN BECAUSE THEY
THE ONES THAT UNDERSTOOD. TAKE
IT WOULD TAKE THE HIT SO I
TOTALLY. SO I PROMISE YOU WHEN
YOU KNOW THEY WILL DO IT I WILL
DEFINITELY MEET WITH THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU-
CENTER LATER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY BUT I HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE OFF IF THAT'S
OKAY. MY UNDERSTANDING IS A LOT
OF WHAT- THE OPPOSITION IS. BUT
THEIR OPPOSITION IS IT CAN NOT
FREEZING THAT'S RIGHT AT ALL.
THIS BILL IS AN ATTEMPT TO
REGULATE AN UNREGULATED PORTION
OF THIS INDUSTRY YES THANK YOU
AND SOME OF WHAT THE OPPOSITION
IS WORRIED ABOUT IS ALREADY
HAPPENING YES AND YOUR BILL IS.
GOING AFTER THIS IN A SMALL WAY
AND HOPEFULLY IN A BIGGER WAY
SOON YES AND IT'S BEEN A
CONSUMER PROTECTION AS YOU KNOW
YOU CAN BUY THIS THIS PRODUCT
MOST SO MANY PLACES IT'S JUST
AMAZING. AND THERE'S NO IDEA
WHAT'S BEEN IF IT'S BEEN TESTED
IT'S NOT REGULATED THAT'S WHAT
IT IS IT'S ABOUT CONSUMER
PROTECTION FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE USING A PRODUCT THAT
IS. GOOD AND THEN ON TO NOT TO
GET SICK SO IT'S ALL ABOUT
SAFETY CONSUMER PROTECTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. RIGHT ANY
OTHER- QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SO
YES SIR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR- AND IT HERE AT THE
DEBATE AND I'M SENSITIVE TO
BOTH SIDES- I DO KNOW THE
AUTHOR HOWEVER- HAS EXPRESSED
WANTING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS- I HAD CONCERNS WHEN I
HEAR ON A DOCTOR TALK ABOUT THE
HELP. IT TO CHILDREN AND
EXPOSURE AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK I WOULD NEED TO
TAKE DEEPER TO UNDERSTAND. ME I
DID HERE RIGHT NOW IT'S ABOUT
SAFETY AND MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING BUT I CANNOT HELP BUT-
THINK THAT THERE IS OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO WORK AND REALLY
TALENT INTO SOME OF THAT
OPPOSITION AND COME TO AN
AGREEMENT SO HOPEFULLY. THAT
WILL HAPPEN BUT I WILL ALSO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR MELINDA'S. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- SO.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT- ONE OF THE STATEMENTS
HERE IN THE ANALYSIS- G. R. S.
WHICH IS THE GETTING IT RIGHT
GROUP A PROJECT OF A PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE. THEY'RE
SAYING THAT THE CAP OF POINT 3%
THC MEANS THAT A TEN OUNCE
BEVERAGE COULD CONTAIN AS MUCH
AS EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLIGRAMS OF THC WHICH WOULD
BE EIGHTY FIVE TIMES THE
LEGALLY ALLOWED DOSE OF THC AND
CANNABIS EDIBLE- WOULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT FOR ME PLEASE FOR
CORPORATE RATE ONLY THAT'S TRUE
ON MY ONLY TO MY EXPERT
WITNESSES OF ABOVE MISTER
MARTIN OR MR BERNACCHI K. G.
MISTER MARTIN'S COMING UP TO
THE MICROPHONE. I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT THE AMENDMENT
THAT YOU ACCEPTED ALSO TRIED TO
DRESS THAT IT RADIATION BUT-
REMARKS PLEASE. WELL MISTER
JERRY TOOK THE WORDS OUT OF MY-
THE CHAIRMAN OBVIOUSLY IS
CONCERNED. ON THAT ISSUE AS
WELL AND WE WORKED WITH HE AND
HIS STAFF OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS. TO COME WITH UP WITH THAT
AMENDMENT THAT BASICALLY LIMITS
THE EXTRACT THAT GOES INTO THE
PRODUCT NOT THE ENTIRE PRODUCT.
TO THAT ZERO POINT 3% OF THAT'S
REQUIRED UNDER FEDERAL LAW THE
CONCERN HAS BEEN EXPRESSED AS A
ZERO POINT THREE WOULD APPLY
TO. A TWELVE OUNCE BEVERAGE
INSTEAD OF THE HALF AN OUNCE OR
SO OF EXTRACTED MY GO TO THE
PRODUCT. THIS WILL ONLY APPLY
TO THE EXTRACT AND NOT TO THE
ENTIRE PRODUCT. TO THOSE EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLIGRAMS WILL
NEVER FORGET A PRODUCT. SO IF
YOU WOULDN'T MIND WE HAVE AN
AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE I'M SURE
ARE LISTENING TO THIS TESTIMONY
IF YOU COULD BOIL THAT DOWN
INTO SOMETHING THAT'S MORE.
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR THE AVERAGE
PERSON WHO ISN'T YOU KNOW- A
POLICY TYPE OF PERSON PUT IT IN
LAYMAN'S TERMS FOR THOSE WHO
ARE LISTENING PLEASE. I WILL
TRY AS THE LETTER FROM PH II-
HELPLINE THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT A BEVERAGE THAT WOULD
HAVE TEN OUNCES OF PRODUCT AND
THEN APPLYING THE ZERO POINT
THREE AND THEIR CALCULATION
WHAT WOULD YOU CALL EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLIGRAMS OF
THC. BY PUTTING A CAP ON IT AS
THE CHAIR HAS REQUESTED WE ARE
NOW BOILING DOWN THAT PRODUCT
TO JUDGE THE EXTRACT THAT GOES
INTO THE PRODUCT TO MAKE IT A
HEMP CBD PRODUCTS. AT THAT
POINT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
VERY SMALL AMOUNT THAT GOES
INTO THIS TEN OUNCE BEVERAGE.
SO THE ZERO POINT THREE THAT'S
REQUIRED UNDER FEDERAL LAW THE
CAPITAL T. H. C. ZERO POINT
THREE. APPLIES TO THAT LITTLE
BIT OF EXTRACT SO IT DOES NOT
APPLY THERE'S NO THC AND THE
REST OF THAT. TEN PLUS POUNDS
OF- NINE PLUS THOUSANDS OF THE
BEVERAGE. SO- IF IT WORKS
AGAINST WHAT LITTLE BIT OF THC
IS ALREADY AGAIN IN THE
PRODUCT. I HOPE THAT WAS MORE
CLEAR I'M NOT I'M NOT A
SCIENTIST HEY. I WAS NOT THAT
CLEAR NO NO THAT THAT THAT'S
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR. EXPLANATION-
I. WELL YOU THAT AND LISTEN TO
THE- I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND-
THE CONCERNS. ON THE SIDE OF
THE OPPOSITION THOUGH I DON'T
KNOW THAT IT WARRANTS-
OPPOSITION FOR ME. AND I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT- THE- YOU KNOW
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY HAS-
MAKING HAY OVER THE- DANGER
THAT THIS MAY POSE TO MINORS.
AND ALL THE WHILE THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IS TARGETING MINORS-
THE- MINERS AREN'T ALLOWED TO
TAKE PART IN CANNABIS PRODUCTS
UNTIL YOU KNOW THEY'RE THE AGE
OF TWENTY ONE THE CAN'T-MISS
INTEREST INDUSTRY IS IN FACT
TARGETING MINORS AND I KNOW
THIS BECAUSE I'M THE MOM OF
FIVE CHILDREN AND SO I SEE IT
AND I KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON SO I
DON'T. KNOW THAT IT'S GENUINE
TO SUGGEST THAT THE- THE-
THEY'RE SO DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HARM THAT THIS MAY
CAUSE TWO CHILDREN- I DON'T.
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK OF MY
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED SO
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK U.
S. SENATOR'S OFFICE S. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I HAVE BEEN
WATCHING THIS DISCUSSION BEFORE
I GOT ON THE FLOOR TODAY AND I
THINK MY- FRIENDS FROM LONG
BEACH FOR CALLING IN- I KNOW
THAT THEY ARE A VERY VERY MUCH
A DEEP INTO THIS THIS BILL AND
THEY HAVE THEIR VERY STRONG
OPINIONS AND I CERTAINLY SHARE
A LOT OF THOSE CONCERNS BUT-
MY- CONCERNS ARE ALSO WERE
RAISED WITH. WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
IMAGES FROM SAN FRANCISCO AS
WELL AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THESE
SMALLER- CANNABIS ENTITIES AND
I HOPE SHE CONTINUES TO DO THAT
ESPECIALLY AS IT PERTAINS TO
DRESSING THE TESTING ISSUE THAT
I KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW-
WHICH SEEMS TO BE THAT THE ROOT
OF THE ISSUE- I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AS OF YET BUT I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY- BUT I
WOULD LIKE IT I KNOW. GOOD
FAITH EFFORTS SHOULD CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS AND HEAR THE
CONCERNS A LOT OF WORK AND
CLEAR BACK HOME THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS SEEING
NONE- SUMMER I WANT TO THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL- I KNOW WE HAVE TO FIRST
OF ALL IT KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
VOTERS MADE CLEAR THAT- THEY
WANTED- MARIJUANA LEGALIZED IN
THE STATE- WHEN IT COMES TO HIM
MORE PARTICULARLY UNFORTUNATE
WE DON'T HAVE A- FOR REGULATION
SO THE. THING IS YOU POINTED
OUT- THINGS ARE HAPPENING IN
FACT FOR THE PEOPLE AND YOU
KNOW AS PETERSON I TOO AM
CONCERNED ABOUT EXPOSURE OF
CHILDREN- BUT I WOULD MAKE NOTE
OF THAT- WITHOUT THIS BILL-
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
FACT THIS BILL PUTS LIMITS ON
THAT- MAYBE NOT LIMITS THAT-
SOME PEOPLE ARE ENTIRELY-
THRILLED WITH BUT I'D ALSO SAY
THAT SOME BILLS LIMITS ARE IN
THE CONTEXT THE FACT THAT THE
VOTERS LEGALIZED. WANT SO WE
UNFORTUNATELY WE- WELL
FORTUNATE UNFORTUNATELY
BASICALLY THE PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO. BAN THIS ALL TOGETHER
PERHAPS- AND- YOU KNOW THAT
WOULD BE GOING AGAINST THE
CENTURY THE OVERALL WILL OF THE
VOTERS WHEN HE CAME TO THE
LEGALIZATION OF MARIJUANA
ITSELF. SO I THINK THIS IS IN A
IN A SENSE IS ALSO AN EMERGENCY
BILL- BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO
HAVE AT LEAST SOME FORM OF
REGULATORY. MECHANISM I'LL ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT- CERTAINLY.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE FDA BUT
THE FDA HASN'T ACTED YET AND WE
CAN'T JUST LEAVE IT AS A
VACUUM. UNTIL THE FDA ACTS-
BECAUSE AGAIN I THINK IN MY
PERSPECTIVE TO CHILDREN BEING
AFFECTED. I APPRECIATE YOU-
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE I GUESS THE
DOSAGE OR EXPOSURE OF WHICH I
JUST REMIND IS. IS BASED ON THE
FEDERAL STANDARD AND ENSURES
THAT NO ONE'S GONNA BE EXPOSED
ANYMORE THAN THE FEDERAL
STANDARD READIES IN PLACE. AND
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE YOU
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. ON SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT THE OPPOSITION HAS
CONCERNED ABOUT- SO CERTAINLY I
MEAN YOU KNOW. IT'S I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE
MOVE FORWARD THIS LEGISLATION.
AND WHAT THAT WHICH I LIKE
CLOTHES. OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
JUST SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS
LIKE TAKE THOSE SERIOUSLY AND I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. LET'S FACE IT. YOU
CAN GO TO ANY STORE RIGHT NOW.
AND YOU CAN GET THIS PRODUCT
EVEN THOUGH THERE'S NO LABELING
ON IT. I WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S
ONLY SAFE. FOR SENIOR CITIZENS
BUT A FATHER'S THE DECIDE TO
USE THIS PRODUCT WHETHER IT'S A
CREAM. FOR THOSE. OF THE
BEVERAGE WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE DO
SOME REGULATION REGULATION ON.
SO WITHOUT MY CLOTHES. AND THEN
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK AND- I.
BELIEVE I HAVE NOT RECEIVED THE
MOTION YET. LOCATED IN BY
CENTER ADMIN THE MOTIONS PASSES
AMENDED. BUT ROOM- AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE. A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I AIKMAN. EGGMAN
EIGEN SOLACE HI GONZALEZ I GROW.
GROVE I HER TADO LLEVA LEE MON
ROTH OUR ROTH IRA RUBIO HI
RUBIO I WINNER WINNER I. SO THE
GROSS CURLY EIGHT ZERO OR HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATORS
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTES OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE-
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY NINE BY SOME
MEMBER MER SUCI. ALL RIGHT- I'M
GOING TO. CLEAN UP THE PODIUM
FIRST BUT WELCOME. RIGHT. RIGHT
WELCOME CENTER MAYOR CITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS AND-
BEFORE I GO ANY FURTHER I FIRST
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF- I WILL BE ACCEPTING
ALL COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE SPECIFIED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS- WHICH SHOULD REMOVE-
HOPEFULLY THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WILL
CONFIRM THAT THEY'RE REMOVING
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THIS THIS
MEASURE. I'M PRESENTING EIGHTY
TWO SEVEN NINE. TO HELP PROTECT
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. THIS MEASURE
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE SAMPLING. WITH SUPPORT FROM
THE A. R. P. THE CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM. THIS BILL WILL
TEMPORARILY HALT NURSING HOME
EVICTIONS AND INVOLUNTARY
TRANSFERS UNLESS MEDICAL
MEDICALLY NECESSARY DURING THIS
COVERT STATE OF EMERGENCY.
SENIORS LIVING IN NURSING HOMES
AS WE ALL KNOW HAVE BEEN AMONG
THE MOST VULNERABLE TO COME OF
IT. IN THE EARLY STAGES OF THE
PANDEMIC THEY ACCOUNTED FOR
ALMOST HALF OF ALL DEATHS. DUE
TO COVE IT. ACCORDING TO A NEW
YORK TIMES ARTICLE THAT IS
REFERENCED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. NURSING HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. HAVE BEEN DUMPING
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS AND HOMELESS
SHELTERS AND OTHER UNSAFE
FACILITIES DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF HIGHER
PRIVATE INSURANCE OR MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ONE EXAMPLE IS ROCK
PORT HEALTHCARE SERVICES WHICH
MANAGES THE STATE'S LARGEST
CHAIN OF FOR PROFIT NURSING
HOMES THEY HAVE BEEN REPEATEDLY
CITED FOR ILLEGAL EVICTIONS. IN
LOS ANGELES MY JOIN AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO. PRESENTS BOYLE
HEIGHTS WHERE. THE COMPANY
PACIFICA THE OWNER OF ANOTHER
FOR PROFIT NURSING HOME CHAIN
STARTED TRANSFERRING RESIDENCE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE RAGING
PANDEMIC SO THAT THEY CAN
CONVERT THE FACILITY INTO
LUXURY APARTMENTS. I AM
CONTINUING TO WORK. ON
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION. AGAIN I BELIEVE
THAT THE HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION I
SHOULD BE REMOVING THEIR
OPPOSITION. BUT I ASK YOU
SENATORS AT THE PLEASE HELP
PROTECT VULNERABLE SENIORS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC FOR BEING
EVICTED OR FOUR FROM SUFFERING
TRANSFER TRAUMA. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. BECAUSE FINANCE-
SUPPORTERS SAY THE MEASURE
TODAY IS- MIKE DARK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM. AND FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARNED FOR TINY.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH SUMMER
REMEMBER SU CHI AND I LIED
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH MY COMMITTEE AND
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- THAT
WE'VE OFFERED SO WITH THAT
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
TESTIFYING SUPPORT I BELIEVE
THEY'RE BOTH ON THEY'LL BOTH
BE- THROUGH OUR TELEPHONIC LINE
SO MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ONLINE MIKE DARK FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM AND WARM
FAIR TINY- COMMITTEE MEMBER
FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER- CAN
PLEASE BRING THEM ON THE LINE
AND AGAIN EACH OF YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH
MIKE DARK. YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND A SPECIAL THANKS
TO THE AUTHOR FOR THIS LIFE
SAVING BILL. I'M LIKE DARKER
STAFF ATTORNEY IN CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM. A NONPROFIT ESTABLISHED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE THAT
ADVOCATES FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
LONG TERM CARE I'M HEARING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR ABC. TWO
SEVEN NINE. I ASK THAT EACH
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
IMAGINE WHAT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
LIKE IF IN THE LAST YEAR YOU
HAD TO LEAVE YOUR CAREER. YOUR
HOME YOUR FAMILY AND FRIENDS
AND NEIGHBORS. TO LIVE IN A
NURSING HOME. HE WOULD HAVE
LIVED IN THE LAST YEAR IN NEAR
COMPLETE ISOLATION. SEEING
PEOPLE DIE ALL AROUND DURING
THE PANDEMIC. UNDER CURRENT
RULES YOU CAN BE TOLD THAT YOU
WILL BE EVEN BIGGER. THIRTY
DAYS. EVEN THOUGH YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY AREN'T EVEN ABLE TO
CURSE IT'S A NEW FACILITY THAT
MIGHT. BECAUSE OF ONGOING
COVERT VISITATION RESTRICTIONS
THAT THAT SOUNDS UNFAIR THAT'S
BECAUSE IT. IS BROKEN. STATE
AND MUNICIPAL THAT EARLY CAN.
LOW MANY HELD. WE JUST FILE IT
CAN EXTEND TOWARDS ON THE-
YESTERDAY. BUT NONE OF THOSE
RULES HAVE APPLIED TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG. ISOLATED
ELDERLY ANDDISABLED PEOPLE
LIVING. THERE EIGHTY TWO SEVEN
MILLION WOULD REQUIRE THAT ONLY
FINANCIALLY HEALTHY FACILITIES.
CORPORATE EARLY RESTRICTED FROM
UNDERTAKING CERTAIN INVOLUNTARY
CONVICTIONS DURING THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. UNLIKE OTHER
LANDLORDS SUBJECT TO DEPICTION
MORATORIUM HOWEVER UNDER EIGHTY
TWO SEVEN NINE USABILITY CAN
STILL BE REIMBURSED. UNDER
PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICAID AND
MEDICARE FOR CONTINUING TO
HOUSE RESIDENTS. WE URGE YOUR
YES CLOSE TO THAT IMPORTANT BUT
TEMPORARY. MEASURE TO HELP OUR
SENIORS AND DISABLED PEOPLE
MAINTAIN SAFE PLACES TO LIVE
DURING. THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT'S NOW BRING ON. SOME
WARNED TIME. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRIS SOULES FORMER
FAMILY MEMBER WARREN COURT
CONNIE- SENATOR AND CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THERE'S A
PLEASURE TO BE PARTICIPATING IN
A COMMITTEE HEARING BOX AGAIN.
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
ISSUE SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE IT
RELATES TO OUR ICONIC JAPANESE
AMERICAN INSTITUTIONS CALLED
KATO NURSING HOME. NURSING HOME
FACILITY FIVE YEARS AGO WE WERE
TOLD WE COULD PICK UP AND THE
NAME WAS CHANGED TO TALK ABOUT
GARDENS. RECORD GARDENS THE
PHONE CABLE NURSING HOME HAS
BEEN CULTURALLY SENSITIVE HAS
PROVIDED CULTURAL POLLUTE
CULTURAL AWARENESS AND JAPANESE
LANGUAGE SERVICES TO THE
ELDERLY IN THE JAPANESE
COMMUNITY IN THE GREATER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA FOR
DECADES. BUT UPON SALE PACIFICA
CHANGEOVER WHAT ABOUT A PROBLEM
RELATIVE TO EIGHTEEN P.
SERVICES BECAUSE OF THE PACIFIC
OF ULTIMATE PLAN WAS TO CHANGE
THE SERVICES OVER TO HOUSING.
SO THE PANDEMIC OF TRICKS.
PULLED SPEND EXASPERATED. MANY
JUST WELL IT'S TO HOW CARE
EXAMPLE. HIM BACK ON
COMMUNITIES COLOR CALLED. THAN
THEY ARE IN A BIG. IT ALSO
SHOWS OVER TREATMENT THAT WE
APPROVE ALL RIGHT IF THAT
TOWARD THE L. ACCORDING EXAMPLE
OF THE- SO THE FACT ABOUT
GARDENS ATTEMPTING TO CALL
THEIR ENEMY CARE. SO THEY CAN
CHANGE THE PORTION OF THE
CAMPUS OVER TO THE HOUSING THE
IRONY IS THEY ARE TRYING TO
TRANSFER PEOPLE TO ANOTHER
FACILITY THAT THE OLD CALLED
KATE HI. LOS ANGELES GARY LOS
ANGELES ALTHOUGH THOSE ELDER
CARE HAVE THE WORST RECORD OF
ANY CORPORATE NINETEEN
INFECTIONS AND. DEATHS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I THE
COAST TO TELL THAT TO ME THAT
THE ONLY THING HAVE BEEN THANK
BUT THE TRACK RECORD IS BEEN
REAL QUICK ONLY A FAMILY. WELL
THE TO DO LIST PUBLIC BEING
THAT THERE. IF YOU COULD TURN
THERE. IN THE MAIN OPTION
CALLED FOR TO THE FOLKS IN THE
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITY AND
TALK ABOUT CARTON. EIGHTY TWO
SEVEN NINE HELPS PUT TEMPORARY
STOPPAGE ON THE SEPARATE UNTIL
BETTER OPTION COULD BE
DEVELOPED IN SITUATIONS TO
PROVIDE RELIEF. TO KIND OF HELP
HERE THAT ARE ELDERLY OU
SHOULD CLICK ON THE SATELLITE
ALONG. URGE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO PLEASE SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN NINE THANK BEING
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MORE TWO
CHANNEL COUNTRY I WILL PUT
THEIR EFFORTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- THAT'S NOW MOVE ONTO
DIGITAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY NINE BEGAN
WITH THE PUBLIC GALLERY. I SEE
SOMEONE PUBLIC GALLERY. OKAY
NAME OR POSITION POSITION ONLY
IF YOU. HOLD ON A MOMENT THE
MICROPHONE ON OKAY PLEASE BEGIN
AGAIN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROUGH SCHOOL K. YOUNG YOUNG
FORMER BELLEVILLE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER- ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FOURTEEN DELEGATES AND NUMBER
OF FAVORITE SENIORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH THE STAFF AT
ANY SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE PUBLIC GALLERY IS MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SAYING NO ONE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE ON
TO TODO TO OUR TELEPHONIC LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY
TWO SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. NINE ONE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TO BE WRITING ABOUT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE COMPLAINT THANK YOU
SO MUCH OKAY THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NINE ONE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SH GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARI KALINA MODEL ALSO
FORMER CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
AGING AND LONG TERM CARE
COMMITTEE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
NEXT LINE. NINE ONE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON TURNED.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON TRIM
PANEL MEMBERS WHICH IS DOCTOR
DAVID EASY MALDONADO CIGAR
SENIORS NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
pAFTERNOON DOCTOR PATTED
COMMITTEE I'M DR KENNETH TIGHE
ISHIDA I AM CURRENTLY THE
CHURCH CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
THE CATO PACIFICA COMMUNITY
ADVISORY BOARD. CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. ONE TWO OH ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE TO GET THE WORD
NATIONALIZATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
SHOWING SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JAMIE A
DOLLAR MEMBER OF PROGRESSIVE
ASIAN NETWORK TRANSACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
PAN AND MEMBERS THIS IS DOCTOR
CANNOT GRAHAM. SON OF THE
SECTOR I HIP RESIDENT AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NINE TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SARAH MAY
NOT THAT THE FLOOD CONTROL OF
COUNTY RESIDENTS AND I URGE
SENATORS WHO CAN READ THE
ARTICLE YEAH. SEVENTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE ONE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MAUREEN
CRUISE AND A REGISTERED NURSE
AND I'M DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL ANGELES CHAPTER AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
TWO SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE TWENTY FOR YOU
MAYBE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER. COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS AFTER
TESTIMONY THAT WE HAVE LISTED
SO WOULD THEN TAKE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
KNOWING THAT I DON'T SEE ANYONE
AT PUBLIC ALEX MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WOULD TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. NINE ONE NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS BARBARA
PLAYED THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. AND I JUST WANTED
TO LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT
HE H. IS REMOVING ITS
AMENDMENT TAKEN PICKING. AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE PEOPLE WORKING ON
THOSE DEMANDS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. EXLINE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
LET'S BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES SIR WINNER MOVABLE OKAY
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WIENER- SAYING NO THE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. THE SUMMER MESSAGE
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH I KNOW
THIS IS A- CHALLENGING
SITUATION GOING ON- AND IN LOS
ANGELES BUT ALSO THE BROADER
ISSUES THAT YOU ALSO TRYING TO
DRESS- WITH THIS BUILD
APPRECIATE AGAIN WORKING WITH
THE STAFF THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU I- MR
CHAIRMAN AS YOU INDICATED
WHILE. THE INSPIRATION FOR THIS
BILL WAS THE LOS ANGELES-
FACILITY THIS A CLEAR THEY HAVE
STATEWIDE IMPLICATIONS WHICH IS
WHY. WE'RE GETTING SUPPORT FROM
THE STATEWIDE NURSING HOME-
ADVOCATES NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS ADVOCATES AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
OKAY SOTHEM IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER WINNER THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. FIRST AMANDA
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CAN I CAN
I AM MELINDA'S SIDE BELINDA'S
I. EGGMAN. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROW HER TADO. LLEVA LEE MALONE
I LIVE ALONE BY ROSS FIVE ROTH
IRA RUBIO. WINNER WINNER I. THE
CURRENT ROLE SIX ZERO LEVEL THE
ROLE ON CALL BOULDER ROLE
CONTRAPTION NUMBERS RIGHT LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO A HIGHER NUMBER
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SUMMER
GONZALEZ AND I KNOW WE HAVE TO
CLEAN THE PODIUM FIRST- OKAY
RIGHT WELCOME. THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- I'D LIKE TO
START BY TAKING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
AB FOUR FIFTY WILL ESTABLISH A
NEUTRAL AND INDEPENDENT BODY TO
OVERSEE PARAMEDIC LICENSURE
DISCIPLINE CURRENTLY THE E. AT
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY ISSUES PARAMEDIC
PARAMEDIC LICENSES CONDUCTS
DISCIPLINARY INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTES COMPLAINTS THE WHOLE
THE SOLE AUTHORITY TO MAKE
FINAL DETERMINATION AND SERVICE
INVESTIGATOR PROSECUTOR JUDGE
AND JURY WHEN TAKING LICENSURE.
ACTIONS EVEN THE PEELS PROCESS-
THERE IS ONE THEY CAN APPEAL TO
AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE BUT
EVEN AFTER THAT LONG PROCESS
THAT IS SIMPLY A PROPOSED
DECISION AND GOES BACK TO THE
E. THE M. SET FOR FINAL
DETERMINATION. IF THE
PARAMEDICS LICENSES REVOKED IT
IS A PROCESS THAT WILL LIKELY
LOSE OUR LIVELIHOOD BECAUSE
MOST APARTMENTS REQUIRE AN
ACTIVE LICENSE AS A CONDITION
OF EMPLOYMENT. NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ISSUED MEDICAL
LICENSE IS LEFT IN THE HANDS OF
A SINGLE INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE A
FINAL AND BINDING DECISIONS
ESPECIALLY SUCH DRAMATIC IMPACT
ON THE ON THE LIVES OF THE
LICENSEES. A. B. FOUR FIFTY-
ESTABLISHA BOARD OF MEDICAL
PEERS AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO BRING BALANCE AND FAIRNESS
TO THE PARAMEDIC DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS- THIS HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND I HAVE I THINK
A WITNESS TO TESTIFY- BECAUSE
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE COMPANY
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH SAM
MEMBER AND BEGIN FISHING YOU
WORKING WITH US ON THE-
CLARIFYING AND I'D LIKE TO PUT
IT THAT WAY. ALL RIGHT LET'S.
BRING ON MODERATOR. LET'S BRING
ON OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO
CHRISTY BOWMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERSWHO CAN PLEASE
BRING HER ON THE LINE AND- YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS CHRISTY BELMONT I'M
HERE ABOUT THE THIRTY THOUSAND
CAREER FIREFIGHTING. AND
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
PERSONNEL IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
INCLUDES OF COURSE OUR
PARAMEDICS. DID YOU KNOW. YOUR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. OPERATE THE
STRESSFUL AND UNPREDICTABLE
ENVIRONMENT IT'S A MUST ALSO
OPERATE UNDER A STRICT SCOPE OF
PRACTICE. THE MASALA CLEARLY
ARTICULATED PROTOCOLS WHEN
PERFORMING PATIENT ASSESSMENTS.
AND RENDERING CARE IN THE
FIELD- AUTHOR. QUITE ELOQUENTLY
DESCRIBED THE BILL I WOULD JUST
MAYBE JUST TALK ABOUT A COUPLE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE SUFFERED.
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
COSTING THEM YEARS OF THEIR
LIFE AND THEIR WORK. OF THE
DEPLOYMENT- WE HAD TO ORANGE
COUNTY PARAMEDICS WHO WERE
CLEARED OF DISCIPLINE BY THEIR
EMPLOYER ONLY TO HAVE. THEM TO
CHARGE THEM WITH INCOMPETENT TO
SPEND THEIR LICENSES ON APPEAL
AND THEY'LL J. FOUND. THAT
THERE WAS. AN UNSUBSTANTIATED
CASE. AND RECOMMENDED NO ACTION
BE TAKEN. THE ANSWER IS STILL
COMPOSED THE ORIGINAL
DISCIPLINARY PENALTY OF
SUSPENSION. ANOTHER INSTANCE A
SIMPLE CASE OF MISCOMMUNICATION
RESULTED IN THE REVOCATION OF
THEM. A LOS ANGELES FIRE
DEPARTMENT MEDIC ONCE AGAIN THE
L. J. FOUND THE CASE ROUGHT BY
INCIDENT WHERE THE PROPOSED
DISCIPLINE- THE THAT DECISION
WAS SET ASIDE IN FAVOR OF
STRIPPING THAT MAKE OF HIS
LICENSE- THE MEDIC APPEALED TO
THE SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE ALSO
FOUND THAT ANSWER COULD NOT
TRUSTING THE CHARGES REMANDED
BACK SIX YEARS LATER. INTO THIS
PROCESS THE PARAMEDIC IS STILL
BATTLING THIS ISSUE IN FRONT OF
THE NEW A. L. J. AS- PRESCRIBED
BY THE APA THE SYSTEM IS
BROKEN. EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY WILL
BRING A NEUTRAL CLEARLY DEFINED
AND CONSISTENTLY ADMINISTER
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS WHICH WILL
INSPIRE CONFIDENCE FROM
LICENSEES EMPLOYERS. AND THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITY THE
PROCEEDINGS ARE FAIR. AND SWIFT
AND PROTECT THE PUBLIC. WE ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH A WELL KNOWN MOVE
ONTO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY OF
THE YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON THE PUBLIC ALEX MOVED
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SING ON
ROOM TO I. FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
THERE. NINE TO TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TO TWELVE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY TWO
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU. WE'LL NOW
MOVE ON TO- TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION-
WITNESS NOTED HERE LET'S GO TO
A PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE
THROUGH TWENTY FORTY SINGLE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT ON THE CASE OKAY THANK
YOU A MODERATOR LET'S NOT BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES
CENTER WINNER OF THE BILL RIGHT
TO MOVE BY SERRA WINNER- SEEN
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THIS AMERICANS ALSO. AT THE
SUPPORT WE PROVIDE DUE PROCESS.
ASSESS YOUR FIREFIGHTERS THANK
YOU FOR MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD- WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN IRAQ
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH SO IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER WINNER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN HI AND I'M MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S I AIKMAN HI EGGMAN
EIGEN SOLACE HI CAN SELL US ON
A GROWTH OF. HER TADO LLEVA THE
MOON HI LIMONEIRA BROTH ALL
RIGHT ROSS I RUBIO RUBIO I
WINNER. WINNER I. OKAY ROLLS
EIGHT ZERO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT DO YOU HAVE
OTHER AUTHORS HERE OKAY SO I
UNDERSTAND- S. CENTER WINNER
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF THE SEVEN MEMBER SANTIAGO IF
YOU WISH YOU CAN PRESENT FOR
YOUR DESK OR FROM THE PODIUM
WHICHEVER YOU WISH. OUR PRESENT
MY OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER
SANTIAGO THESE BEGINS OUR
WINNER. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AND I- I'M
PRESENTING FOR SUMMER SENT IAGO
WHO IS- STUCK AND COMMITTEE SO
PLEASE. BEAR WITH ME- SO-
PRESENTING AS BEFORE EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
SOMEONE MEMBER SANTIAGO- AND
THAT SOME MEMBERS HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S.
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH HIM AND HIS
STAFF. I'M EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN CREATES THE PROTECTION OF
PATIENT CHOICE AND TELEHEALTH
PROVIDER ACT. TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS RECEIVE ADEQUATE AND
EFFICIENT TELEHEALTH SERVICES.
AS WE CREATE MORE ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH SERVICES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ESTABLISH ADEQUATE
SAFEGUARDS FOR PATIENTS TO
MEASURE THEIR QUALITY CARE. THE
BILL GIVES PATIENTS THE OPTION
TO USE A PROVIDER OF THEIR
CHOICE EITHER IN PERSON OR VIA
TELEHEALTH. WITH ME. TODAY TO
TESTIFY- CINDY HILLARY FROM THE
CALFORNIA. MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND LIZ HOLMES. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR RIVALS. OKAY. THANKS VERY
MUCH SIR WINTER. THE MODERATOR
BRING A TO THE LINE OUR- IT'S-
WE HAVE CINDY HILLARY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND FOLLOWED BY LIZ HELMS FROM
CALIFORNIA CRY CARE COALITION
OF THESE- EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
MAXIMUM PERFORMANCE FOR BOTH OF
YOU TOGETHER. HELLO I'M TWENTY
HILLARY REPRESENTING THE FIFTY
THOUSAND DOCTORS AND MEDICAL
STUDENTS THAT MAKE UP THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE STOCK- EIGHTY FOUR FIVE
SEVEN. I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
EXPRESSING MY GRATITUDE FOR THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF WHO WORK DILIGENTLY WITH
STAKE HOLDERS AND THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE. THE CLARIFY AND
STRENGTHEN THE MEASURE. THE
END. WILL HELP AT THE TREATMENT
MODALITY IS TO ALLOW PATIENTS
INTERACT WITH THEIR CHILDREN
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN OR OTHER
PROVIDER WHEN IN PERSON TODAY
WOULD BE CHALLENGING. THE MAIN
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF PUBLIC HEALTH UTILIZATION IN
THE PLAY. AND THE MOTHER IS NOT.
I INNOVATION LIMIT EXTENT OF
TELEHEALTH. WHAT FOUR FIFTY
FIVE DIED IN THAT HELP PLAN DO
NOT YOUR PATIENT THE THIRD
PARTY CORPORATE TELEHEALTH
COMPANIES. MOREOVER THE BELFAST
FRAMEWORK THROUGH WHICH
PATIENTS TO DO ACCESS. THE
SERVICES RECEIVE HIGH QUALITY
INTEGRATED CARE INCLUDING
MAINTENANCE OF THEIR PATIENT
RECORDS. IT DOES THIS BY
REQUIRING PLANTS TO INFORM
PATIENTS OF ALL OF THEIR
OPTIONS FOR MAKING AN
APPOINTMENT TO SEE A POSITION
THAT POWERHOUSE. WHETHER THAT
CLEANER USUAL POSITION MAKING
AN APPOINTMENT WITH ANOTHER
NETWORK POSITION OR WHEN
APPLICABLE USING THEIR OUT OF
NETWORK BENEFITS. YET NON
CONTRACTED POSITION IN THEIR
AREA. IF THE PATIENT HERE'S
THEIR OPTIONS AND STILL COLLECT
THE THIRD PARTY CORPORATE.
ACTIONS THAT'S THEIR CHOICE.
WHEN THEY DO EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN FURTHER GUARANTEES THAT
THE RECORD OF FACT INTERACTION
GETS RELAYED BACK THIRTIES WILL
FORCE HERE. HELLO HOPE MUST BE
CONSIDERED ANOTHER TOOL A
DIFFERENT MODALITY ACROSS WHICH
PATIENTS AND PHYSICIANS CAN
MEET. NOT DIFFERENT KIND OF
CARE. THE CARE PROVIDED TROUGH
TELEHEALTH HE CARED THAT
PRIORITIZES POSITIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES IN AN INTEGRATED
MANNER. EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
TAKES IMPORTANT STEPS TO ENSURE
PATIENTS RECEIVE QUALITY CARE
NO MATTER THE MODE OR PROVIDER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MARIA NOW WITH SPRING ON LIST
FROM THE CAL CRISIS COLON.
HERE'S DR HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY ENGLISH HELLO
AND THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION. THE CALGARY FRONT
YOUR COLLISION OR DO YOU NEED A
LINE COMPLETING NONPROFIT
VOLUNTARY HEALTH ASSOCIATION
CONSUMER HEALTH ORGANIZATION
AND PROVIDER GROUPS UNITED TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS WHAT KIND OF
CONDITIONS OR DISEASES. OUR
MISSION IS TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THE TWO APPROACH
AFFORDABLE QUALITY HEALTH CARE.
ON BEHALF OF THE FORTIES I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT EIGHTY FOUR
FIVE PM IN. THE COLD AND THEN
WE CAN CERTAINLY CHANGE THE WAY
PATIENTS RECEIVE HEALTHCARE
TELEHEALTH IS PROVEN TO BE AN
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT. HERE PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS ARGENTINE REALLY
POPULAR COORDINATE BETWEEN
MULTIPLE PROVIDERS PRIMARY CARE
AND SPECIALISTS AND THANK THE
PIER IF NOT THEN WE EXANSION
OF TELEHEALTH IT'S BEEN A
BLESSING FOR THESE PATIENTS. IT
ALSO MEANS HOWEVER THAT CHRONIC
KIDNEY PATIENTS ARE THE MOST AT
RISK WHEN CAN BECOME FRAGMENTED
IF THE PATIENTS WE REPRESENT
OUR TEAM BY THIRD. SO THIRTY
NOT RELATE TO THE PATIENT CARE
TEAM IT CAN DISRUPT HUNTERDON
DISEASE NOW MAINTENANCE PLANS.
THAT ARE YEARS IN THE MAKING
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE ROUTE.
EIGHTY FOUR FIVE SEVEN WILL
ENSURE THAT THE RECORDS ARE
ENTERED INTO A PATIENT RECORD
SYSTEM SHARED WITH YOU KNOW ALL
THESE PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER. OR
OTHERWISE PROVIDING. HERE
EIGHTY FOUR POINT SEVEN STRIKES
THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN
ALLOWING THE THIRD PARTY
CORPORATIONS TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE WHILE PLACING IMPORTANT
SAFEGUARDS AROUND HOW THEY ARE
USED FOR THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR VOTE IN
FAVOR OF THIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN WILL BE HELD
PUBLIC GALLERY. ALL RIGHT. A
SCENE OR THE PUBLIC GALLERY
LUTHERAN TWENTY FORTY AS SEEN
ON MON TWENTY FORTY OF
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MR
KERR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. FOUR FIFTY SEVEN YOU
MADE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO.
TWENTY SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS JUSTIN
RANDALL CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WHO ACTUALLY HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF MANY POSITION ON
THE SPELL AND DENTISTS ARE
CURRENTLY EXEMPT FROM. AT THE
BILLABLE WE'RE SEEING THE SCENE
DURING HAPPENING ON THE DENTAL
SIDE PROVIDING AN AMENDMENT
THEY'RE LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS
AND THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
EXCLUSION- REMOVED AS WELL AS
AND A FREQUENCY NOTICED THE
DENTAL PATIENTS KNOW HOW THESE
TELEHEALTH VISITS WILL IMPACT
THEIR ANNUAL MAXIMUM BENEFIT.
IDENTIFICATIONS THAT ARE THE
SAME PROTECTION BUT THEY WOULD
RECEIVE ON THE MEDICAL SIDE
EVEN. WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AND- I THINK SO MUCH. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT LINE. NINE TO EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU HIM DON'T HAVE
AN ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. FIVE TO TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
SHERATON BOLLOCKS ON BEHALF OF
THE DOCK DOCK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE
THEY HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL NOW MOVE O TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN- MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE OR TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. STEPHANIE
WATKINS FROM DISSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND JED
HAMPTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS. I
WILL BEGIN WITH- STEPHANIE
WATKINS AND AGAIN- TWO MINUTES
EACH- MAXIMUM FOUR MINUTES FOR
BOTH OF YOU TOGETHER. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF ME
WALKING DOWN THE HALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
I'D LIKE TO FIRST EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION BUT THE AUTHOR
SPONSORING COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO HEAR OUR
CONCERNS AS WELL AS FOR THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
BE TAKEN TODAY. EARLY IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE. AS WE
MENTIONED IN OUR EARLIER
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE BILL OUR
MAIN INTEREST AND CONCERN HAS
ALWAYS BEEN CENTERED AROUND
ENSURING THAT WE DON'T
UNINTENTIONALLY PUT BARRIERS
AND- DELAY IN RELEASING
INSURANCE FROM POCKETING
SPECIFIC TYPES OF TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. WHEN THEY NEED THE
MOUNTAINS. AS WE SEE THE THIRDS
OF THE PROVIDING OF VALUED AND
COMPLIMENTARY BENEFITS TO
PATIENTS. I WOULD NOTE THAT WE
MAY SEEK SOME CLARITY WITH
RESPECT TO A FEW OF THE TERMS
USED IN THE BILL RELATED TO
PROMOTION AND COORDINATION OF
SERVICE BUT CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS WE
EVALUATE. OUR POSITION GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LET'S NOT ON TO J. HAMPTON FROM
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS. MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE GET HIM THEN I'LL BE
HAPPY. TO HELP PLAN I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR. MAKES
UP WITH THEIR WORK ONLY FORTY
SEVEN- AS MY COLLEAGUE.
MENTIONED WE ARE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THE MINUTES OF THE
FILM AND HAD SIMILAR CONCERNS
RELATED TO THE PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THE BELT. AND AROUND TEN OF
BARRIERS TO LOWLY WISHING TO
ACCESS OUR TOP THIRTY BILLION
INDIVIDUAL HEALTH PLAN. I AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED YOU STILL
HAVE. QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF AN ADULT ALTHOUGH
IT DOES APPEAR THAT THE MINUTES
ARE POSITIVE. STEPS IN
ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- FOR YEAH I FOUND
THE BACK. OKAY THANKS VERYMUCH
WE'LL NOW MOVE THIS NEW
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FOUR FIFTY SO TOGETHER PUBLIC
OUT SINGLE OUR IT'S MATURE
TWENTY FOUR SEEN ON RUN TWENTY
FOUR MODERATOR PLEASE THE LINE
FOR WITNESS AN OP. TO EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN YOU MADE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. NINE TO TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EASTERN MEMBERS JOHN WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE APP EMERICA
HEALTH. HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
A HIP- WOULD AFTER THE COMMENT
THE CAPTAIN ACT LOOKING LIKE TO
ALSO THANK THE- AUTHOR SPONSOR
AND COMMITTEE FOR THE CONTINUED
DIALOGUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ONE. NINE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS CAME TO MEET HIM AFTER
TECHNICIAN. GET AWAY FROM AN
ATTACK HAS RAISED SOME CONCERNS
AND IT'S ABOUT THE- THE BILLING
PRESS. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
Q. OKAY LET'S BRING YOU BACK TO
TWO MAJOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SIX OF
THE BILL IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SIR
EDMUND- SIR WE- AGAIN THEN. ON
BEHALF OF US I KNOW YOUR FIRST
MAYBE HALF OF THE SUMMER
SANTIAGO APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
AT THE WORK WITHOUT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT AS WE ADOPT
THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES WHICH
CAN BE EXTREMELY HELPFUL IN
TERMS OF TELEHEALTH. THERE WERE
NOT. WE'RE SEEING PEOPLE ON THE
TELEHEALTH AND DEPRIVING THEM
OF THE IN PERSON- A SERVICE AND
SO I THINK IT'S A REALLY
REASONABLE SAFEGUARDS ARE PUT
IN PLACE. BEFORE WE SEE THE
EXPLOSION OF TELEHEALTH WHICH I
THINK IS GOING TO BE PART OF
THE FUTURE. ALSO IT'S A GOOD
BILL AND ASK FOR AN IPO. OKAY
THANK YOU AND THEN MAKE THE
VETO MY ARTICLE ANOTHER BRIEF
CALM BEFORE WE TAKE THE VOTE
YEP THIS IS I THINK THE MAN
IT'S REALLY ABOUT BEING SO WE
DON'T HAVE FURTHER
FRAGMENTATION OF CARE. SO AS
NOT TO POINT THAT OUT- OKAY THE
DATA TO MOVE BY SIR EDMUND THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST THE MAN REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS TO
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HICAN I. MELINDA'S SEGMENT
BY SEGMENT I CAN SOLACE HI AND
SO AS I GROW. FURTADO LEYVA.
THE MON I. THE MON BY ROSS
THANK GROWTH IRA RUBY. HI RUBY
I WINNER. WINNER I. OKAY FOR
THE CURRENT ROLE IS SEVEN ZERO-
AND WILL CALL THE ROLL OPEN
BEFORE YOU BEGIN WITH THE NEXT
ONE ACTUALLY I HAVE TO RUN OFF
THE COMMITTEE SO CENTER ADMIN
DO YOU MIND TAKING OVER.
SCHERING HERE OKAY. THE I'M
VACCINATED I GET FROM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR WE
WISH YOU LUCK IN THE COMMITTEE-
SENATOR WIENER ARE YOU GOING TO
BE FROM DOING THE NEXT BILL AS
WELL YES I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I AM PRESENTING AV FIVE
SEVENTY ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
SUMMER SANTIAGO- AND HEALTH
CARE ACT- AND I'M- ON BEHALF OF
THE SUMMER SANTIAGO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S. AMENDMENTS EIGHTY
FIVE SEVENTY WILL ALLOW ADULT
CHILDREN TO ADD THEIR DEPENDENT
PARENTS WERE STEPPARENTS TO
HEALTH CARE PLANS- THE PARENT
OR STEPPAENT MUST BE THE
FEDERAL DEFINITION OF A QUOTE
QUALIFYING RELATIVE. MEANING
THAT THEY RELY ON THEIR ADULT
CHILDREN FOR MORE THAN 50% OF
THEIR FINANCIAL SUPPORT. OTHERS
NO AGE REQUIREMENT- THE BILLS
RECENTLY AMENDED AND NOW ONLY
APPLIES TO THE INDIVIDUAL
INSURANCE MARKET NOT EMPLOYER
SPONSORED HEALTH PLANS. THIS
BILL WILL SAVE FAMILIES MONEY
ON HEALTH CARE COSTS BY
ALLOWING THEM TO COMBINE COSTS
AND PROVIDES A GREAT OPTION FOR
MIXED STATUS FAMILIES AS
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS ARE AN
ELIGIBLE FOR COVERAGE. UNDER
COVERED CALIFORNIA- WITH ME
TODAY ARE- ARE OUR MAIN
WITNESSES MICHAEL MARTINEZ FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ON BY BEHALF OF
COMMISSIONER ON A LOT OF- AND
THEN- BRUCE BRUCE HINES WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
HERE. FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR IF WE COULD PLEASE OPEN
IT IS MR MARTINEZ IN THE
CHAMBER. I'M ON THE PHONE SURE
EDMONTON OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN
A PHONE LINE FOR MISTER
MARTINEZ R. FIRST PERSON. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE ADMIN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL MARTINEZ. SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER CARLOTTA THE
TELEPHONE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. HE IS VERY PROUD TO
BE THE SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE SEVENTY AND THEN WE REALLY
WANT TO THANK YOU FAMILY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND OF COURSE SENATOR
WE KNOW FOR PRESENTING- THIS
IMPORTANT HEALTH ACCESS MEASURE
KNOWN AS THE PARENT. HEALTHCARE
ACT. EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN EXPANDING
COVERAGE OPTIONS IN THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET TO WORKING
FAMILIES. WORKING FAMILIES CAN
CURRENTLY BUY SEPARATE POLICIES
AND THE INDIVIDUAL MARKET FOR
THEIR DEPENDENT PARENTS YET AT
A SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE
FAMILY BECAUSE EXISTING LAW
FORCES THE FAMILY TO PAY
SEPARATE OUT OF POCKET COSTS
AND MEET SEPARATE DEDUCTIBLES
POINT FOR THE WORKING FAMILY
AND ANOTHER FOR THE DEFENDANT
PARENT. THIS BILL EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY WOULD CHANGE THIS BY
ALLOWING THE FAMILY. INCLUDING
THE DEPENDENT PARENTS TO BE ON
ONE SINGLE POLICY. COMBINING
THEIR OUT OF POCKET COSTS AS
WELL AS THEIR DEDUCTIBLE TO
SAVE SOME MONEY. FIFTY FIVE
SEVENTY FOCUSES ON THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET BECAUSE IT IS
CONSIDERED A MARKET OF LAST
RESORT. FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITHOUT EMPLOYER BASED
COVERAGE. ALLOWING ADULT
CHILDREN TO THEIR PARENTS TO
THEIR FAMILY POLICY LOWERS THE
FAMILY'S COSTS WITHOUT IMPACT
TO THE RITUAL OF THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS
WOULD HAVE BOUGHT AN INDIVIDUAL
POLICY ANYWAY. NOW FOR MOST
FAMILIES IF THE DEPENDENT
PARENT QUALIFIES FOR MEDI CAL
OR MEDICARE DOCUMENT PROGRAM
WILL BE A BETTER DEAL FOR THE
FAMILY. BUT FOR CONSUMERS
WITHOUT ACCESS TO THESE
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS FOR THEIR
DEPENDENT PARENTS. WILL PROVIDE
SOME AN END TO TOY. AS THEY
DECIDE THE COVERAGE THAT BEST
SUITS THE NEEDS FROM HER FAMILY.
WHEN WE NEEDED SHARES CHILDREN
OUR PARENTS WERE ALWAYS THERE
FOR US. AS OUR PARENTS AGE A
LOT OF US IN TURN HAVE BECOME
THEIR CARETAKERS AND THIS IS
GOING EVEN HARDER TO THE
PANDEMIC AND RESULTING ECONOMIC
CRISIS. IN CLOSING NOW THAT OUR
PARENT TEACHER WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CARE FOR THEM AS OUR
PARENTS TOOK CARE OF US WHEN WE
WERE CHILDREN. PART OF THAT
CARE SHOULD BE AN OPTION TO ADD
THEM TO OUR SAME INDIVIDUAL
HEALTH COVERAGE WITH EIGHTY
FIVE SEVENTY THIS CAN BE A RIP
REALITY SO THAT THERE CAN BE.
SO THAT WE CAN BE THERE FOR
THEM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ITEM THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER MARTINEZ AND
WE HAVE ALSO BRUCE HINES. A YOU
SUFFER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ARE
ARE YOU PREFER OKAY HIS RETURN
OKAY SO LET'S GO TO THE LEAD
OPPOSITION- WHICH IS JET
HAMPTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS. A
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE UNDER ADMIN
AND MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
SETTING UP YOUR CALL CORNETT
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLAN. I
REGRETTABLY WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY NOW WE WOULD LIKE. TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. MANY SOUTH
WORKING WITH US ON THE FILM. I
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT WHILE WE
LEAVE THE BILL IS WELL
INTENTIONED ANYMORE CAPRICORN
THE GOLDMAN FAMILY COVERAGE THE
EAGLES CURRENTLY WITHOUT
COVERAGE. WE ARE CONCERNED
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY. THE ONLY
INCREASE PREMIUMS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR COVERAGE IN THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET. ACCORDING TO
ESTIMATES CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFIT YOU PROGRAM EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY ONE COULD PREMIUM.
OPERA BETWEEN TWELVE TO FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS I AM ALSO
INCREASE CARSHARING PAID BY
INDIVIDUALS IN THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET. TAKEN TOGETHER WOULD BE
AN ADDITIONAL MANDATE ALSO
MOVED HIS LEGS THE LEGISLATIVE
SESSION BUT WE DO HAVE. A
CONCERN THAT THE FILMING ONLY
FURTHER INCREASE THE COST OF
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
PARTICULARLY FOR FAMILIES TO
BUY COVERAGE OUTSIDE OF THE
EXCHANGE. ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT TE PROPOSAL YOU
FROM. FORTY QUESTIONS
UNANSWERED WITH RESPECT TO HOW
THIS BILL WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED.
QUICKLY. IT WILL IMPACT. THE
INTERACT WITH OTHER PUBLIC
OPTIONS SUCH AS MEDICARE
MEDICARE OR OTHER TYPE OF
COVERAGE. WE BELIEVE THE
DANCERS- THE ANSWER BECAUSE- A
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THE
CALIFORNIA RIGHT BEFORE ON THE
GOAL DO YOU RECALL THE COURT
WILL COME. ALL HELP. WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I STEPPED WALKED NOW OF
LIFE. AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF ME
WATCHING FROM BEHIND THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
I WOULD LIKE ECHO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS JUST
HIGHLIGHT A FEW ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS. WELL WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND THE
BELL IN THE PLOT THE GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA IS AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT THE BILL MAY HAVE ON THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET ESPECIALLY
THE OFF EXCHANGE MARKET YOU
KNOW IT'S INCREDIBLY PRICE
SENSITIVE. AS MY COLLEAGUE
HIGHLIGHTED SOME OF THE
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS WE HAVE
WITH RESPECT TO IMPLEMENTATION
WE THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT
THESE QUESTIONS BE ANSWERED
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD. AS WE
WOULD NOT WANT TO CREATE A
SITUATION WHERE INDIVIDUALS
COULD RECEIVE. SUBSIDIZED
COVERAGE THROUGH THE EXCHANGE
WOULD INADVERTENTLY JEOPARDIZE
THEIR COVERAGE LASTLY I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW THEIR CONCERN WITH
THE CURRENT IMPLEMENTATION TIME
FRAME OF THE BILL AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS FILED THEIR TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWO RIGHT
FILINGS FOR REVIEW BY THE
DEPARTMENT. AND MAY. IMPACT
CREATED BY THIS BILL WOULD
CERTAINLY NEED TO BE INCLUDED
YET DUE TO THE TIMING OF THE
CELL PLANT MANAGERS AND NOT BE
ABLE TO CONSIDER THIS AS A PART
OF THEIR TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWO GREAT DEVELOPMENT.
FOR THAT REASON WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE BILL
IMPLEMENTATION DATE EXTENDED
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IN ORDER TO GET
HEALTH PLANS INSURERS NECESSARY
TIME TO DEVELOP THEIR ACTUARIAL
METHODOLOGIES. FOR THESE
REASONS REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING AN OPEN DIALOGUE
WITH BOTH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS. OF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TODAY THANK YOU. THE
YOU VERY MUCH- LET'S GO NOW TO
PHONE LINE. OF ANY OPPOSE. OR
AN OPPOSITE. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SEVENTY
MINUTE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NINE TO SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS LINDA WAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
NINE TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BRANDED MARQUEE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE TWO TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND GRAMMAR VERA I'M
HAPPY THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE TO TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
APPLE MARKET HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS- WOULD JUST ECHO THE
CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS THAT
HAPPEN ACTIVE COVERAGE THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NINE TO FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANA DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MATTER
MODERATOR NOW WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SENATOR
RUBIO. FOR FIRST OF ALL I THINK
I KNOW THE OTHER IS NOT HERE-
BUT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I'M JUST- YOU KNOW AS I
WAS LISTENING TO THE COMMENTS I
WAS THINKING ABOUT THE
ACTUARIAL METHODOLOGY AND-
IMPLEMENTATION DATE- IS THERE.
I'M NOT SURE IF I CAN ASK- WE
DO HAVE A TECHNICAL WITNESSED A
WEEK IF THEY CAN TALK ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
CHALLENGES AROUND THAT A LITTLE
FURTHER ON THAT OPPOSITION AND
THE PROPONENTS. JUST SO I CAN
SPEND JUST ON THAT PIECE A
LITTLE BETTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER MARTINEZ FOR MISTER
HINES WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR CAN YOU COME WITH THE
CAR INSURANCE. AT THIS TIME OUR
TEAM INTERVENTION EARLIER-
CERTIFICATES IS ON THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET THE FAMILY
WITH DEPENDENT PARENT. UNDER
CURRENT OPTION WOULD BE TO
PURCHASE AN INDIVIDUAL POLICY
FOR THAT. WITH A SEPARATE
DEDUCTIBLE IN A SEPARATE
MAXIMUM OUT OF POCKET SO IN
TERMS OF PREMIUM AND HACKED TO
THE PREMIUM IMPACT DOES NOT
AFFECT THE RISK POOL COULD
AFTER WHAT WOULD BE A LOT.
ANYWAY CIVIL THE TROOPER
ANALYSIS REGARDING INCREASED
PREMIUM EXPENDITURES MOST
LIKELY REFLECTS THE FACT THAT
THEY WOULD BE MORE PEOPLE
COMING INTO THE MARKET. FOR
THIS COVERAGE- AND ALSO MORE
PEOPLE PAYING- THE COLUMN ABOUT.
CAUTIONARY BECAUSE WE ARE A
COUPLE. WITH REGARD TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AMENDMENT
CARCHIDI NUMBER TAKEN TODAY-
PROVIDES THAT ALL CHRISTIANS
WHO WOULD BE QUALIFIED FOR
MEDICARE WOULD BE INFORMED OF
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE STATE'S
COUNSELING SERVICE HI CAP TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY MAKE IT
CONFORM TO CHOICE REGARDING
WHICH- OPTION WOULD BE BEST FOR
THEM. THANK YOU. SINCE YOUR
QUESTION CENTER. YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYTHING
ELSE ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY WOULD THERE BE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL SO MOVED WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
LEYVA I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT I THINK YOU KNOW I THINK
WE ARE ALL AS WE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COST OF
HEALTH CARE- BUT FOR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS LIKE MINE WE HAVE
MANY MULTI GENERATIONAL
FAMILIES WHO ARE LIVING
TOGETHER IN A MIXED STATUS
FAMILIES THIS JUST SEEMS LIKE
IT MAKES SENSE WE KNOW THOSE
WHO ARE IN THEIR SENIORS OR
THOSE WHO SOMETIMES HAVE SOME
OF THE GREATEST NEEDS THAT A
LOT OF PREVENTIVE. HELP WORK
KENAN CAN HELP SO RESHAPE
MISTER SANTIAGO BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND THE SENATOR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR
PRESENTING IT TODAY. WE ARE
GOING TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE. ON
APPROPRIATIONS AS WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR SENATOR LABOR.
CONSULTANT COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HAND BELINDA'S
AIKMAN HI EGGMAN AIKEN SOLID
SIDE CONSOLES I GROW HER TADO
LEYVA LEAVE EILEEN MOANED HI
THE MON HI ROSS ROSS I RUBIO HI
RUBIO I WINNER HI YOU KNOW I.
IT IS SEVEN ZERO WILL HOLD THAT
OPEN FOR NOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW NEXT UP WE HAVE A
SEVEN MEMBER TEAM WITH AB
TWELVE HUNDRED PLANT BASED FOOD
PACKAGING COOKWARE HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS WELCOME MR TANK THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
MOMENTUM HAPPILY. ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS ON MAYBE TWELVE
HUNDRED THE B. TWELVE HUNDRED
THE SFER FOOD PACKAGING AND
COOKWARE APOTEX CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
BY REDUCING HUMAN EXPOSURE AND
TO AN ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION FROM PFAS AND
OTHER. HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS THE
SOUTH IS A CLASS OF OVER NINE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL FOREVER
CHEMICALS THAT HAVE BEEN
DETECTED IN 98% OF AMERICANS
ARE THESE DANGEROUS CHEMICALS
ARE FREQUENTLY FOUND IN OR TAKE
OUT CONTAINERS ARE COOKWARE.
AND FROM THERE THE LEACH INTO
THE FOOD THAT WE EAT INDIVIDUAL
COMPANIES LIKE MCDONALD'S AND
CHIPOTLE IN OTHER STATES LIKE
NEW YORK HAVE ALREADY STARTED
TO PHASE OUT OR BAN P. FAST FOR
PAPER BASED FOOD PACKAGING. A
RECENT REPORT FOUND THAT 80% OF
NONSTICK PANS AND 20% OF
BAKEWARE TESTED CONTAINED A
COATING MADE FROM P. FAST THE
CITY FOR FOOD PACKAGING
COOKWARE BANS THE USE OF
INTENTIONALLY ADDED P. FAST IN
PLANT BASED FOOD. PACKAGING
REQUIRES COOKWARE MANUFACTURERS
DISCLOSE THE USE OF P. FAST
FAIR AND OTHER CANCERS
CHEMICALS FROM THE DTS HE'S
KENNEDY CHEMICAL LISTING THEIR
PRODUCTS AND PROHIBITS
MISLEADING MARKETING CLAIMS ON
COOKWARE CLAIMING TO BE FREE OF
THE SPECIFIC HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL
ONE OTHER SIMILAR CHEMICALS ARE
PRESENT. I'M PROUD TO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN A READ OUT FROM
THE ENERGY C. AS WELL AS NANCY
BREWER MEYER THE BREAST. CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS. THANK YOU
MUCH FOR CHECKING OUT LET'S GO
TO ANNA READ PLEASE WITH AN RTC.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ANNA LIED AND I AM AN
ARTISTICALLY PRENTICE ON PIZZA.
AND EASY SUPPORT AT TWELVE
HUNDRED TO RESTRICT THE
UNNECESSARY USE OF PIZZA- I'VE
MENTIONED A LARGE CLASS OF MAN
MADE CHEMICALS THAT HAVE GROWN
INTO. A GLOBAL ENVIRONMENTAL
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT. ONLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE TRUE PERSONAL
OFTEN CALLED FOREVER CHEMICALS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T BREAK DOWN.
HOW THE MOBILE SPREADING
QUICKLY IN THE ENVIRONMENT AND
THE CONTAMINATION THAT'S HARD
TO CONTAIN THEY CAN
BIOACCUMULATE WHAT ABOUT THE
PLANTS ANIMALS AND HUMANS AND
DEVELOPMENT LINKED TO SERIOUS
HEALTH EFFECTS CANTOR FORMER.
DESTRUCTION OR DAMAGE. ACTIVITY
INCLUDING ARAB RESPONSE BACK.
AFFECTED PARTICULARLY
CONCERNING NON MEDICAL BUT
NINETEEN. FINALLY THEY ARE
WIDELY USED IN INDUSTRIAL AND
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES IN MANY
CONSUMER PRODUCTS. RECENTLY THE
MANAGEMENT OF THESE CHEMICAL
COMPANY FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON
ONE CHEMICAL AT A TIME THE
PROJECT NOT BE AFFECTED BY
CONTROLLING WIDESPREAD EXPOSURE
TO PIZZA BECAUSE- OTHER PEOPLE
AND- ASKING ABOUT THAT THEN-
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE TO BE WRECKED.
TO REPLACE THEM THE MAGNITUDE
OF THIS PROBLEM DEMANDS A MORE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
APPROACH WHICH IS WHY PROMINENT
SCIENTISTS AND MEDICAL
ORGANIZATIONS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD. THIRTEEN O'CLOCK THIS
APPROACH TO MANAGING PEOPLE.
INCLUDING THE FIFTH OUT OF ALL
NONESSENTIAL. OR UNNECESSARY
USES OF PEOPLE. ARE YOU READY
PEOPLE OPTICAL BUT IF YOU'VE
GOT THE USE OF PEOPLE WHO
FIREFIGHTING LAST YEAR. IN
ADDITION THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL IS
ALSO PURSUING A CLASS STEVE
MANAGEMENT PIZZA. FAVORITE
ADEQUATE HIGH PREVALENCE OF
PIZZA. IN PLANT BASED FOOD
PACKAGING. PRODUCT INCLUDES
CONSUMERS TO P. FIVE FEET AND
THROUGHOUT THE CONTAMINATION OF
WATER AT THE PRODUCTS
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFECYCLE.
PHOEBE TWELVE HUNDRED- ANY
UNNECESSARY GETS TO KEEP UP
WITH THE PRODUCT CATEGORIES.
AND HELP PROTECT OUR FAMILIES.
AND COMMUNITIES FROM TOXIC
CHEMICALS. AN EIGHTY THREE OH
WHO SCORED THE COOK DISCLOSURE
FOR OF THE WHICH COLLEAGUE THE
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS WITH THE SCRIPT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT
RECORDED NANCY. MEYER SENIOR
POLITICAL STRATEGIST FOR THE
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SCHERING MEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
A B. TWELVE HUNDRED. MY NAME IS
NANCY HERE MEYER I WORK FOR
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL'S. CO SPONSORS THE
CPP CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH CLEAN WATER ACTION
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
THEN OUR DC. YOU JUST HEARD
FROM ANNA WHY PEACE HAS
CHEMICALS IN FOOD PACKAGING OR
SO CONCERNING. THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT SAFER ALTERNATIVES ARE
ALREADY AVAILABLE AND IN USE IN
FACT MAJOR COMPANIES INCLUDING
MCDONALD'S WHOLE FOODS CHIPOTLE
RIGHTED AND MOST RECENTLY
WENDY'S. ARE ALREADY FACING
PEACE RESTAURANT. STATE AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE ALSO
ACTING INCLUDING NEW YORK STATE
AND MOST RECENTLY CONNECTICUT.
OTHER STATES ARE ON THE BRINK
OF FOLLOWING SUIT AND
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BAN THESE
CHEMICALS WITHOUT DELAY. I
DON'T WANT TO ADDRESS THE
COOKWARE PORTION OF THE BILL.
RECENT TESTING FOUND PEACE OUT
SUCH AS P. T. F. C. ALSO KNOWN
AS TEFLON. AND THE HORMONES
HORMONE DISRUPTING CHEMICAL
BISPING AWAY OR BPA IN THE
CODING TO COOK AND BAKE WHERE.
IT CAN BE RELEASED INTO THE AIR
WHEN HANDS REACH HIGH
TEMPERATURES EXPOSING BOTH
PEOPLE AND PETS. YET NO
DISCLOSURE IS REQUIRED AT THE
STATE OR FEDERAL LEVEL.
ADDITIONALLY COOKWARE PACKING
PACKAGING AWESOME CLAIMS A
PRODUCT IS FREE OF A SPECIFIC
PIECE FAST CALLED PFOA OR PFOS.
EVEN CONSUMERS THE FALSE
IMPRESSION THE PRODUCT IS FREE
OF ALL SIMILAR TOXIC CHEMICALS
IN FACT I AM GRATEFUL PEOPLE
ARE FREE ARE OFTEN MADE FROM
ANOTHER FORM A FEW SHOWERS.
CONSUMERS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
IS TOXIC CHEMICALS ARE IN
COOKWARE MANUFACTURER SHOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED TO MISLEAD
CUSTOMERS. EIGHTY TWELVE
HUNDRED ADDRESSES BOTH OF THESE
CONCERNS. THE AUTHOR IN THE
CONSTRUCTORS HAVE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS. IN ITS
CURRENT FORM MAYBE TWELVE
HUNDRED PROTECTS PUBLIC HEALTH
AND PROVIDE IMPORTANT
DISCLOSURE TO CONSUMERS.
WITHOUT UNDULY BURDENING
INDUSTRY ON BEHALF OF THE CO
SPONSORS AND OVER FIFTY
SUPPORTERS OF EIGHT TO TWELVE
HUNDRED I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I SEE
SOMEBODY UP IN THE IN THE
CHAMBERS YOU WOULD LIKE TO JUST
AT THIS POINT JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT. SURE MY NAME IS SUSAN
LITTLE I'M WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF AB TWELVE
HUNDRED. WE I AM HERE TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT OF THE
OTHER CO SPONSORS INCLUDING
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL CLEAN WATER
ACTION CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT AS
WELL AS IN BIRMINGHAM WORKING
GROUP. AND TO JUST CALL OUT
THAT THERE ARE FIFTY FOUR OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WHICH INCLUDE COMPANY IN
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATIONS PUBLIC
AGENCY ASSOCIATIONS.
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION ORGANIZATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS CONSUMER ADVOCACY
GROUPS COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
WOMEN'S ADVOCACY GROUPS IN
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS. I WOULD ASK THAT
THE MEMBERS REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS FOR A FULL
LIST OF THE NAMES OF THE
SUPPORTERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- NOW LET'S GO TO THE
LEAD OPPOSITION WAS ON THE
PHONE LINE WE HAVE- TIM SHAW
STICK WITH AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL. YOU DON'T EXIST GIVING
NOPE WE HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT IN THE
CHAMBER I'M SORRY MR IT'S JUST.
GO AHEAD PLEASE A NAME AND
AFFILIATION. THE NOON CLINTON
OF ACT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE BUILDING WISHING TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME. OKAY BACK
TO YOU MR CYSTIC. THANK YOU-
YOU'RE A MAN AND A GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS- CONGESTED
WITH AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY OUR COALITION
CURRENTLY HAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. BUT FIRST OFF
I WANT TO EXTEND OUR THANKS TO
OUR CUSTOMER CAME IN THE STAFF.
OF THE BILL'S SPONSOR- THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND ITS
MARKET WITH MANY STAFF OR THE
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE OUR
COALITION TO DISCUSS. ISSUES
AND CONCERNS WE HAVE WITH THE
BUILDER WAS INITIALLY
INTERVIEWED. WELL WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT IT MAY BE
AMENDED. ADOPTED PRIOR TO. THAT
THE WARNING LABEL REQUIREMENT.
ALL THE COMMUNITIES TODAY
REGARDING THE SCOPE OF
DEFECTIVE PRODUCTS AND OTHER
KING DID- THAT ADDRESS
COMPLIANCE COUNT THIS. WITH
THAT THE AMENDED THIRD. BUT WE
ARE INTERESTED IN FURTHER
DISCUSSION AROUND A COUPLE OF.
GOOGLE IMPLEMENTATION POINT-
THESE ARE READ IT THE
DEFINITION OF INTENTIONALLY
ADDED IN ARTICLE ONE OF THE
BILL. IN ORDER TO REMAIN OPEN
FOR SOME INTERPRETATION- WE DO
THINK THAT ADDITIONAL CLARITY
AND- EVEN THE LANGUAGE IN
ARTICLE CLEARLY WORTHY OF
DISCUSSION IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL CERTAINTY FOR
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY. BUT
THE SECOND POINT I LIKE TO MAKE
IT THE EFFECTIVE DATE IN
ARTICLE ONE- IT INCLUDING THE
STAFF ANALYSIS THERE IS A
NATIONAL EFFORT TO FADE OUT.
THE PACKAGING- INNING ON
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
BUT HAD GET TO WORK WITH THE
CITY STATE EIGHTY SIMILAR DATE
I'LL BE INCORPORATED INTO THIS
BILL. AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR BEING IN THE MEDIA
SPONSORS FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT
WITH THE CAR I WOULD CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS MADE TO
DATE I LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL
GO TO DON KOPECKY CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS. AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU MATT
CHAIR NOT DON'T CAP WITH MCCUE
K. CANA SAID IF SOMEHOW OF THE
COW. MANY AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. ALSO WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON AT TWELVE HUNDRED. WE
APPRECIATE THE MANNER BY THE
OCTOBER SPONSOR SUCH FAR TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
MANUFACTURING COMMUNITY IMPACT
OF THE BILL. INCLUDING REMOVAL
OF THE PROBLEM SIXTY FIVE LIKE
MORNING AS WELL INCLUDING THE
DEFINITION OF INTENTIONALLY
ADDED IN ARTICLE TWO.ALIGNS
WITH CURRENT CONDITIONS IN THE
CODE. THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
AN INTEREST IN ATTRACTING A FEW
REMAINING IMPLEMENTATION IS
SHARED TO INSURE THE BILL IT'S
WORKABLE AND FOCUSED ON THE
CONCERN AT HAND. FIRST THING IN
HERE GREASE OF EIGHT FIFTY IS
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO ALIGN
THE DEFINITION OF A CATCH HE
ADDED IN ARTICLE ONE. RELATED
TO THREE PACKAGE YOU KNOW WITH
THE REST OF THE BILL AND OTHER
SUCH DEFINITIONS THE CODE
TODAY. THE STRUCTURE OF THE
DEFINITION ARTICLE ONE MAY HAVE
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT FOR THE USE
OF RECYCLED MATERIALS ADVOCATE.
TO PRIORITIZE RECOVERY
RECYCLING AND. AN OVERALL
CIRCULAR ECONOMY- AND OTHER
TYPES OF PACKAGE. IT DOESN'T OF
THE- COULD PUT THE AT FOR THE
DAY WITH THE RECYCLING IN. AND
GOALS STATE. I WE WOULDN'T
CONSIDER. OF COOKWARE IN THE
BILL LACKS CLARITY SCOPE. MORE
THE INCLUSION OF THE PHRASE
COOKWARE INCLUDES BUT IS NOT
LIMITED TO. ME CREATE
REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY FOR
MANUFACTURERS AND AFFECTING
WHETHER THEIR PRODUCTS. ARE
SUBJECT TO THESE REQUIREMENTS.
YEAH ANANT NUMBERS PREACHING IT
FURTHER CLARITY IN THIS REGARD
FOR THE MANUFACTURER HAVE A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF THE COLD
COKE PRODUCTS PROJECT TO THE
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS. DOES
THE FED COULD GET TOASTER OVENS
SMALL ARTISTS AND BALLOONS AND
GLASSWARE ETCETERA. FINALLY
WHAT WE APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED.
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER. WE WOULD BRING AN
EMBLEM. AND BEAT CONCERNED WITH
REQUIRING ALL COOKWARE PRODUCTS
TO CONTAIN AN ARM PRODUCT
DISCLOSURE ONLINE DISCLOSURE
AND POTENTIALLY A Q. R. CODE
OUT CREATE A COMMUNITY STAKE
TRASH AT. INTEL TEAM HE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS FOR
CREDIBILITY REGARDING THE
METHOD USED TO CONVEY
INGREDIENT INFORMATION WHETHER
THAT BE ON THE LABEL VIA A
MANUFACTURER WEBSITE. OR A Q.
R. CODES TO NOT BE
UNNECESSARILY DUPLICATIVE AVOID
INCREASED PACKAGING AND
LABELING WAVES AND TO ADDRESS
THE POTENTIAL NEED FOR MORE
SPACE TO DISCLOSE WHAT COULD BE
A MULTITUDE OF CHEMICAL.
NATURALLY OCCURRING ELEMENTS
AND COMPLEX ALLOYS THAT APPEAR
ON THE LISTS OF LISTS
CONTAINING OVER THREE THOUSAND
STEPS A DAY. AND MAY NOT AFFECT
HUMAN HEALTH OR ENVIRONMENTAL
RISKS. BUT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
BE DISCLOSED IF INTENTIONALLY
ADDED TO THE COOKWARE PRODUCTS
AGAIN WE THINK THE AUTHOR HIS
SPONSORS AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS WITH AT TWELVE
HUNDRED. I LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE ACTORS REGARDING.
THEIR MAIN CONCERN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THREE- AND I THINK
THAT CONCLUDES THE OPPOSITION
TO IT- PRESENTATIONS THAT WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WILL
BEGIN WITH THE- PUBLIC GALLERY
SINGLE IN THE PUBLIC GALLERY.
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SCENE ON ONE TWENTY FORTY-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE HUNDRED NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
PARDON THE INTERRUPTION WITH
THAT. THE COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
HAD NOT YET BEENTAKEN WHICH IS
THE O. OKAY SORRY I APOLOGIZE I
THOUGHT THAT WAS THE OFFICER I
JUST CAUGHT THE TALENTS ARE
STILL WE'RE STILL IN TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT. SO AGAIN PUBLIC
GALLERY KNOWN PUBLIC GALLERY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY KNOWN TWENTY
FORTY THAT STAND GO WITH TWO
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A B. TWELVE
HUNDRED OF A TELEPHONIC LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. PEOPLE
AND THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF. AB
TWELVE HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOONTHIS IS ALEXIS CHAVEZ
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE P. TWELVE
HUNDRED. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
TWENTY THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN NUMBERS FOR Q.
DOT COM WE HAVE THE FOLLOWING
CLIENT SITTING COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO NATIONAL STRATEGIC
ACTION CAMPBELL CALIFORNIA
PRODUKTER SHOULD CANCEL AND
STOP WAITING ON SUPPORT AT.
EIGHTY TWO HUNDRED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. MY TWO
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS CHAIR
BRIAN SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STICKS AT NINE IN SPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JENNIFER
WILLIAMS BUT THE EAST BANK
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE TO FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. PRIOR
TO THE MORNING CALL ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF P.
B. TWELVE HUNDRED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO THIS
IS LISA FAMILY ON BEHALF OF THE
CLEAN SEAS COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. MY TWO
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND CAN- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- THIS IS SCHERING GREEN
WITH A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE TO TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT LYDIA WORN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
HUNDRED WE DO HAVE TO. LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON TO
LINE TEN SHOTS STICK FROM THE
MERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL AND
DON KHAKI FROM TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WILL
BEGIN WITH THAT TIM SHOTS.
SHOTS THANK. OH OKAY ALL RIGHT
SORRY OKAY. JOIN LINEHAN OKAY
SO. WE'RE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH ALL RIGHT SO THEY'VE
ALWAYS HEARD THE WITNESS
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY THAT'S WHY
I THINK WE GOT CONFUSION.
ALRIGHT LET'S NOW GO TO AN
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WILL GIVE PUBLIC
GALLERY NO THE PUBLIC GALLERY
IN THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY KNOWN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE TELEPHONIC
LINES TO WITNESS WHO TESTIFIED
WAS TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWELVE HUNDRED. THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
A B. TWELVE HUNDRED YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AND THEN ZERO. NINE TO
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ADAM RILEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS.
ARE WORKING WITH THE COALITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
LINE NUMBERS. NINE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE SEVENTY YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME TO
TRONC USURPATION OFWHAT PARTS
AND ACTUALLY WE ARE CLOSED ON
US AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE TWO FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE HAVE NO RESPONSE
FROM NINETEEN FIFTY THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH
MODERATOR LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
QUESTIONS COMING FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBER CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING SO
HARD TO. TRY AND ELIMINATE THIS
OUT VERY DANGEROUS CHEMICAL AND
I ALSO HEARD FROM I GUESS THE
OPPOSITION. SUPPORTERS HOW HARD
HE HAS WORKED TO REALLY- BRING
EVERYONE TO THE TABLE AND TAKE
EVERYONE'S CONCERNS- SERIOUSLY
AND CLEARLY REFLECTED IN SOME
OF THE DATA IN THE BILL
ALREADY- I JUST WANNA ADDRESS
TWO THINGS AND THAT'S JUST-
AGAIN JUST GIVE THE OTHER
DEPUTY TO SHARE. HIS THOUGHTS.
ARE I THINK THERE WAS A COMMENT
ABOUT THE DEFINITION OF
INTENTIONALITY ADDED. AND THE
PERHAPS THE ABILITY TO
INTERPRET THAT DIFFERENTLY. IT
MAY NOT BE CONSISTENT WITH THE
WAY IT'S USED. BY OTHERS- IF HE
CAN ADDRESS SUCH AS FOR CLARITY
THANK YOU. SEVENTEEN THIRTY
CENTER PUSHES YOUR COMMENTS IN
YOUR QUESTION- WE THOUGHT THAT
THAT WAS THE BEST WAY TO
DEFINE. WHETHER A CHEMICALS IN
THERE I THINK THE POINT IS. TO
IDENTIFY- P. FASTEN THOSE
FOREVER CHEMICALS THAT THAT
WERE REALLY INTENTIONALLY ADDED
RATHER THAN. PERHAPS THERE ARE
SOME ACCIDENTAL ADDITION OR-
SOME SORT OF. ELEMENT THAT WAS
NOT THE INTENTION OF THE-
COMPANY AND WE THOUGHT THAT
THAT WAS THE BEST WAY TO. SORT
OF IDENTIFY THAT PARTICULAR-
PRODUCT BUT AGAIN. WE'RE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS. WITH OPPOSITION
ABOUT WHAT HE WHAT THE MOST
APPROPRIATE WAY. TO IDENTIFY
THAT PARTICULAR ELEMENT AS-
THANK YOU THAT DOES SOUND TO MY
QUESTION ND I YOU KNOW THANK
YOU I JUST I THOUGHT I HEARD
YOU SAY YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT ISSUE- AND DOES
SECONDLY I ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS
THIS BECAUSE I MEAN I'M HEARING
FROM- THE OPPOSITION THE
PROPONENTS. LITTLE BIT OF A
CONFLICT IF I MAY ALSO
ADDRESSES WITH THE OTHER GIVE
HIM THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLARIFY
AGAIN JUST TO MAKE SURE ON.
IT'S CLEAR I MEAN I JUST HEARD
A LOT OF ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS-
STRONGLY SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
WHICH IS GREAT AND I ALSO HEARD
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT. THIS
BILL OR- SOME OTHER PORTIONS OF
THIS BILL MAY BE IN CONFLICT
WITH THE STATE'S RECYCLING
GOALS AND AGAIN JUST FOR
CLARITY CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT.
THANK YOU. RICHARD I DON'T
THINK THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING-
AGAIN THE MADE IMPETUS FOR THE-
HE FAST ESPECIALLY IN FOOD
PACKAGING IS. QUITE OFTEN- TO
SAY IN MY JURISDICTION I'M VERY
FORTUNATE THAT WE ACTUALLY
ALLOW FOOD PACKAGING INTO OUR
COMPOST HOWEVER IF THE FOOD
PACKAGING HAS P. FASTER SOME OF
THESE OTHER- FOREVER CHEMICALS
ACTUALLY POLLUTES THE COMPASS
SO- AGAIN- I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS A PARTICULAR CONFLICT
WITH OUR STATES- RECYCLING LAWS
BUT AGAIN THE ELEMENT WAS TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THESE CHEMICALS
DON'T IN PARTICULAR THE IMPACT
THE COMPOSTING BUT ALSO DON'T
HARM TO INDIVIDUALS FOR USING
IT ON THE OTHER PIECE IS MANY
COMPANIES. FOR TWO LARGE FAST
FOOD COMPANIES THEY ALREADY
PURCHASED- NON P. FAST FOOD
PACKAGING IT'S QUITE RANDOM AT
THE CLUB IT'S BASED ON LOCATION
AND WHICH- WHICH- FOOD
PACKAGING- PRODUCERS ACTUALLY
PRODUCING IT BUT- WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IT BY SENDING SENDING
THIS VERY STRONG SIGNAL LEAST
IN CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE THAT
ALL THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS
ARE PURCHASING FOOD PACKAGING
THAT NO. LONGER HAS THESE
PICTURES CHEMICALS. WELL ONCE
AGAIN JUST WANT THANK THE
AUTHOR HE'S DONE A LOT OF WORK
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE
CONCERNS FOR DRESSING YOU KNOW
THESE ARE JUST MINOR QUESTIONS
FOR CLARIFICATION. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE HIS STATEMENT ABOUT
CONTINUED TO WORK ON THIS AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THANK YOU AND MOVE THE BILL
WHEN APPROPRIATE THANK YOU
THERE'S BEEN MOVED BY SERRA.
IT'S ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE- SO IT AND MAYBE IT
SERIK RAY ASSETS ON CONFIRM YOU
ARE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YES. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
AND I REALLY WANNA THANK YOU
FOR WORKING- SPONSORS WORKING
OF MY STAFF ON THOSE AND- YOU
SURE WE'RE MORE. FOCUSED SO
THAT INTERNET WOULD BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS THE-
PURPOSE FEEDBACK I THINK WE
HAVE REALLY BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY. WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
BUT ALSO WITH THE OPPOSITION.
TO TRY TO HAVE A BILL THAT IS
NOT ONLY EFFECTIVE BUT ALSO
WORKABLE. SO REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITTEE YOUR ASSISTANCE
IN. RESPECT FOR YASSER ARAFAT.
RIGHT THANK YOU OKAY SO THE
BILLS SAID THE MOVE BY SERRA
REVEALED THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST DEMANDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON.
TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FAN HI. PAM I'M MELINDA'S
EGGMAN. EGGMAN EIGEN SOLACE HI
CONSOLES I GROVE. FOR TADO.
LLEVA ALL LEAVE EILEEN MOANED
HI. THE MOON I ROSS OUR ROTH
IRA RUBIO. HI RUBIO I WINNER.
THE THOSE CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO
WILL DEVELOP AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER. THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE BY SUMMARIZED
REGUS. WELCOME. FOR THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE WOULD PROMOTE-
LEARN TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES BY
DOING TWO THINGS FIRST IT WOULD
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO THE INTER
AGENCY COUNCIL ON
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS
BECAUSE THOSE DEPARTMENTS CAN
POSITIVELY IMPACT BURNER AND
OPPORTUNITIES SECOND THIS BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT THOSE
DEPARTMENTS FROM DISCOURAGING
OR NUMBER. OPPORTUNITIES THE
APPEALS TO APPEARS TO BE NO
VALID POLICY REASON TO PROHIBIT
TRAINEES FROM BEING COMPENSATED
FOR THE WORK THEY DO DURING
CLINICAL TRAINING IN THE FIELD.
IN FACT PROHIBITING ARNOLD ARE
DISCOURAGED THE MORE DIVERSE
GROUP OF STUDENTS FROM ENTERING
THE HEALTH CARE FIELD BECAUSE-
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLETE
HUNDREDS OF HOURS OF CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE WITHOUT PAIN MAKING
IT. PROHIBITIVE FOR THOSE WHO
CANNOT AFFORD TO. THIS BILL
THIS COMPROMISE. OF SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE INTERNAL REPORT
PUBLISHED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS LAST YEAR
WHICH IS REQUIRED BY MY EIGHTY
TWENTY ONE OF FIVE AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AT THE TIME AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO SERVE OUR
POPULATION. THIS BILL WOULD
HELP BRIDGE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN STUDENTS AND EMPLOYERS
CAN ENCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
DIVERSE ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS TO
JOIN THE WORK FORCE. COMING IN
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
MATT THE SHEIK REPRESENTING AND
SHOW YOU AND HELEN ROTH DOWD
AND REPRESENTING. THE JEWISH
VOCATIONAL SERVICE. THANKS VERY.
S. AND THEN THE MEMBER- BUT
REGUS AND- THAT'S A MODERATE
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE MATT
LUCE FROM S. A. U. CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL AND HELEN DALAM
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO JEWISH
VOCATIONAL SERVICES BEGIN WITH
METALLURGY. TWO MINUTES GOOD
AFTERNOON JERRY MEMBERS MET
WITH JAY ON BEHALF OF S. U.
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF P. TWELVE SEVENTY THREE.
FIRST I LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIR
AND STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
IN CONTINUING TO CHAMPION
EARNING. MORE WE SHALL GET
PROFESSIONAL. DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT- MY PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL
TOOL TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
GROWING WORK FORCE SHORTAGE. BY
INSURING REGARDLESS OF
INDIVIDUAL SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS- YOU CAN PURSUE
THEIR DREAM OF BECOMING A
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL. I WAS
A MEMBER OF THE EIGHTY TWENTY
ONE OF FIVE COMMITTEE WHERE
LABOR MANAGEMENT EDUCATION
PROVIDERS LICENSING BOARD AND
THE DEPARTMENT. OF RECREATION
STANDARDS CAME TOGETHER TO
CRITICALLY EXAMINE WHAT
CALIFORNIA CAN DO. TO REMOVE
BARRIERS TO EARN AND LEARN
PROGRAMMES. AT TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE TAKES TWO KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE REPORT
TO ADDRESSBARRIERS FOR.
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA THE
FIRST IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
GATEKEEPERS TO HEALTHCARE
CAREERS A LICENSING BOARDS. ARE
WORKING MORE COLLABORATIVELY
COLLABORATIVELY WITH STATE
ENTITIES AND STAKEHOLDERS ARE
WORKING ON DEVELOPING OUR MARCH
STANDARDS. IN THESE
PROFESSIONS. THE SECOND IS TO
ENSURE THAT PROGRAM
ACCREDITATION WHICH IS WHEN A
PRIVATE ORGANIZATION CERTIFIED
PROGRAM NEEDS THEIR- PRIVACY.
ANDERS- THE ARE NOT PREPARED
TO- EARNING MORE. HOW LIGHTING
BOARD AND HOW DEFERRED PROGRAM
THE CREDITORS TO ENSURE THE
APPLICANTS HAD GONE TO A
REPUTABLE SCHOOL. IN IN
ADDITION TO TESTING FOR OTHER
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS. EIGHTY
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE SIMPLY
STATES THAT WHEN A LICENSING
BOARD LOOKS TO A PRIVATE
ACCREDITING BODY WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THOSE BODIES DO NOT
PROHIBIT. PROGRAMS TO BE CLEAR
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT IN
EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
FOUR MANDATE THAT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAM OR OTHER
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS FOR
EMPLOYER PARTICIPATE IN OUR IN
OUR PROGRAM. THIS IS SIMPLY A
REVIEW OF EXISTING LICENSING
LAWS TO ENSURE THAT THE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ALIGNED WITH OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TOOL TWO MINUTES
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR EYES
OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO HELEN
DALVIN. FROM SAN FRANCISCO
JEWISH VOCATIONAL SERVICES. HI
THIS IS REID OUT IN I WAS ALSO
AS NETWORK A MAN OF THE ONE OH
FIVE TASK FOR. IN CURRENTLY
LISTED ON THE ON THE PAYMENT OF
THE- TWO THAT DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND CURRENTLY
SIT ON THE I. AKA HEALTH
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I WON'T
REPEAT A LOT OF SWEAT THAT
MATTER ALREADY SAD BUT JUST TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL- TO
MEET US OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THE THIRD RECOMMENDATION. IS AN
AB TWELVE THIRTY SIX NOW AT A
TRAILER BILL WHICH ADDRESSES
THE LACK OF DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
COLLECTED BY HEALTH LEGISLATION
SIR. BOARDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT PRO IT WILL PROHIBIT A
PRIVATE ACCREDITING AGENCIES
FOR BANNING THE USE OF EARN AND
LEARN. AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT SINCE OVER 18% OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE HASN'T
HEALTH RELATED LICENSURE. AND
HEALTH IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING AREAS IN THE ECONOMY.
ONE OUT OF FOUR JOBS IS
PROTECTED COULD BE RELATED TO
HEALTHCARE. SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT PARTICULARLY STUDENTS
WHO MIGHT BE COME FROM
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS.
GENERAL AND ON. THESE PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE AS IT IS NOW AT THE
THEY CAN'T. BE EMPLOYED AND- IN
A PRO AND EDUCATION PROGRAM NOW
INSTEAD THEY HAVE TO FOREGO
INCOME FOR UP TO TWO YEARS AGO
AND TO DEATH. WITH ONE
EXCEPTION IS EVERYONE AT REALLY
AN EXAMPLE OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING WHICH ALLOWS
HER TO LEARN MODELS. OF THE
INDEPENDENT ROLE AND- WITHOUT
REDUCING THE QUALITY OF THEIR
TRAINING OR THEIR EDUCATION.
THEY CAN GAIN ARE IN LICENSE
HERE IN THE ONE PROGRAM I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED WITH. THIS I
DON'T IAN'S HE WENT FROM FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND A YEAR NINETY
THREE THOUSAND A YEAR AN 85% OF
THE LPN WORK FORCES ACTUALLY
MINORITIES. SO THIS IS A HUGE
WAY OF THEM GETTING INTO VERY
MIDDLE CLASS ARE IN JOBS. LET
ME GIVE YOU A CONTEST WHICH IS
PRIVATE LICENSURE ENTITY FOR
RADIOLOGY TECHNICIANS. THEIR
LICENSE WHO ARE LICENSED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
ACCORDING TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DATA OBTAINING AFTER
OBTAINING A LEISURELY ELEGY
TECHNICIAN DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATION. YOU CAN EARN
BETWEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AFTER FIVE
YEARS OLD AND PLEASE READ THIS
IS ANOTHER GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS. SO WHEN I JUST IN CLOSING
I WANT TO SAY IS I THINK THAT.
CALIFORNIA LAW AUTO SUPERSEDE
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS WRAP UP
AND NOT BLOCKED THE- PAST TWO
AND DISPATCH WITH DANCING THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY THREE-
WILL BEGIN WITH PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SCENE ON ROUTE TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
TO WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN. SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE. NAME OR
POSITION DOES I THINK. OKAY
THANK YOU MR WAITED AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF A B. TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO. IN ONE MOMENT BUT
BOTH MY NUMBERS. HELLO NINETEEN
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HIDE ON
TRANSFORMATIVE. THE CALL CENTER
IN GOLD IN CALIFORNIA. STRONG
POSITION FOR EIGHTY ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE OKAY WE'RE TAKING
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT RIGHT NOW
SO- MODERATOR ANY OTHER AT NEXT
LINE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE WE HAVE TO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
LESLIE WINTER. WITH THE JOINT
REVIEWCOMMITTEE ONEDUCATION
IN RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY AND
LYNN ROLLING FROM THE SOCIETY
OF NUCLEAR MEDICINE MOLECULAR
IMAGING YOU CAN BRING THEM ON
THE LINE- YOU EACH HAVE. WELL
YOU HAVE A LITTLE OVER TWO
MINUTES BECAUSE THE PROPONENTS
WENT OVER I WILL AFFORD YOU THE
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME THAT'S FOUR
MINUTES TWENTY SEVEN SECONDS-
BUT JUST. GIVE ME TWO MINUTE
WARNING KEEP IN MIND YOU'RE
GETTING CLOSE TO THE HALFWAY
POINT. SO BEGIN WITH BLOODY
WINTER. HELLO ON BEHALF OF THE
JURORS HERE TM SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF CALIFORNIA BILL
EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
SPECIFICALLY. EARN AND LEARN
CONCEPTS DUE TO THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT IT WOULD POSE ON YOUR C.
R. T. ACCREDITED PROGRAMS.
HERE'S YOUR KEY CURRENTLY
CREDIT OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FOR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS IN THE
RADIOLOGICAL SCIENCES FORTY OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE CALIFORNIA
AND WE SERVE AS AN
INSTITUTIONAL CREDIT RECORD.
FOR SIX OF THESE PROGRAMS AND
WITHOUT THIS ACCREDITATION
THESE PROGRAMS WOULD HAVE TO
CEASE OPERATIONS DUE TO
STUDENTS BEING INELIGIBLE TO
TAKE THE NATIONAL CERTIFICATION.
CONSISTENT WITH THE STANDARDS
PROGRAMS CONDUCT AN ANNUAL
ASSESSMENT INTERNAL EMPLOYMENT
AND EXTERNAL ACCOUNTABILITY THE
CALIFORNIA CHRISSY PROGRAM
SEVEN STREET SOUND EDUCATIONAL
QUALITY IS EVIDENT BY THE
PROGRAM EFFECTIVENESS DATA. THE
DATA SUBMITTED BY THESE
PROGRAMS FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN ARE REMARKABLE IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I CAN PROVIDE
THOSE STATISTICS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THE
CERTIFICATION EXAMINATION PASS
RATE IS 86% HIGHER IN THE JOB
PLACEMENT RATE VARIES FROM
EIGHTY EIGHT TO A HUNDRED
PERCENT. THIS DATA HOWEVER IS
CRITICAL EVIDENCE THAT
DEMONSTRATES THESE PROGRAMS ARE
WELL ESTABLISHED AND PROVIDE
COMPANY GRADUATE. WORK IN THE
WORKPLACE IS ENTRY LEVEL
TECHNOLOGY CLOSE IMAGE RESEARCH
AND CONTRAINDICATED STATEMENT
THAT GRADUATES ARE NOT PREPARED
TO CORRECT ENTRY. LEVEL
PRACTITIONERS. THE ORACLE DATA
FROM BILLS. ELIXIR THE
IMPORTANCE FORMALIZED
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS WE
IMPLEMENTED STANDARDS FOR
MEDICAL DOSIMETRY TWENTY FOUR
TWO THOUSAND FOUR IT REQUESTED
MEDICAL BILLS IN THE TREE
CERTIFICATION BOARD. PRIOR TO
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE ON
CAPTURING WAS MOST COMMON
METHODOLOGY IN THE EDUCATION OF
A MEDICAL IMAGERS HOWEVER DUE
TO POOR PASTURAGE FOR
CREDENTIALING EXAMINATIONS. THE
MEDICAL DOSIMETRY CERTIFICATION
OR REQUIRE ALL APPLICANTS TO
GRADUATE SO BUT HERE'S THE R.
T. CRAIG KROGER SINCE THIS
REQUIREMENT WAS IMPLEMENTED.
THE FIRST. ATTEMPT PASS THREE
TO DOUBLE. SHARES THE PULSE PER
HIT TO FROM WEARING HIS
CLINICAL HOURS. GUARANTEE TO
ARE NOT TAKING OFF BY THAT IN.
TO PUT IT BACK. ADDITIONALLY
SOME STUDENTS ARE NOT
REGISTERED- LICENSES RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS. FORMALLY THEY
CANNOT PERFORM ANY TASK IN
APPROPRIATE SCOPE OF PRACTICE
WITHIN THE PROFESSION OF THE
RADIOLOGIC SCIENCES.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE NUMEROUS
STATE REQUIRED GRADUATION
CREATURES HERE KEEP CREDIT
PROGRAM TO GAIN EMPLOYMENT
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WOULD
HINDER GRADUATES WHO STATED
CALIFORNIA SEEKING EMPLOYMENT
OUTSIDE THE STATE. IN CLOSING
AS IDENTIFIEDIN THE DOCUMENTS
BARRIERS IN RECOMMENDATIONS TO
FACILITATE LEARNING AND EARNING
TRAINING PROGRAMS. IT WAS NOTED
THAT. SOME WORKERS WERE TO
ENGAGE IN THE DISK WITH YOU
CREDITOR. THE J. R. C. E. R. T.
HOWEVER DID NOT RECEIVE ANY
COMMUNICATION OR GET OUR CREDIT
PROGRAMS OR THE- CALIFORNIA.
THEREFORE THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS FAILED DUE TO LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY DRIVEN INSTITUTE.
THE BILL RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
IN THE ASSEMBLY THIS BILL FAILS
TO RECOGNIZE THE VALUE AND
BENEFITS OF FORMAL TWELVE
STRUCTURED EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
FINISHERS OF QUALITY HERE AND
TAKE THE LIBERTY FINDING
RADIATION THE JERSEY ARE KEY IN
THE CREDIT HELP CORN PROGRAMS
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER EXEMPTING
MEDICAL IMAGING RADIATION
THERAPY AND MEDICAL DOSIMETRY
PROFESSIONALS FROM THIS
LEGISLATION. THE IMPACT OF THIS
BILL WOULD BE FAR REACHING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW BRING
ON LYNNE ROY UNFORTUNATELY THE
FIRST AT THE FAR USED UP MOST
OF THE TIME SO YOU HAVE TO
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY SECONDS. MY
NAME IS LYNNE ROY REPRESENT A
SOCIETY OF NUCLEAR MEDICINE
MOLECULAR IMAGING WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE A B. TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE A NUCLEAR
MEDICINE TECHNOLOGIST INJECT
RADIOACTIVE FOR A FALL
PHARMACEUTICALS AND OTHER DRUGS
TO ILLICIT A METABOLIC RESPONSE
IN PATIENTS. DIAGNOSTIC IMAGES
ARE TAKEN HIGH DOSES OF
RAINFALL MRS CALLS CAN ALSO BE
GIVEN TO TREAT NOTHING CAN
ANSWER YOU COULD MEDICINE
SCHOOLS ARE ACCREDITED BY THE
JOINT. COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
AND NUCLEAR MEDICINE TECHNOLOGY
K. OR SEE AN ANTI CREDIT ASIAN
SHARES A PROGRAM MADE
ACCEPTABLE LEVELS OF QUALITY J.
R. C. M. P. ACCREDITED PROGRAMS
ARE REQUIRED TO TEACH A LEDGE
CURRICULUM DEVELOPED BY
PROFESSIONALS CLASSES CONSIST
ABOUT A LEVEL PHYSICS MOLECULAR
BIOLOGY CHEMISTRY. J. R. C. M.
P. POLICIES PROHIBIT STUDENTS
FROM- ANYWAY JUST A CLINICAL
HOURS ASSIGNED DISTURBANCE
STUDENTS TAKING THE PLACE
CERTIFIED TECHNICAL OUTSIDE
INDIVIDUALS ADMINISTERING
RADIOACTIVE SUBSTANCE. K. B.
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE APPEARS TO
NOT RECOGNIZE ACCREDITING
INSTITUTIONS THAT DO NOT ALLOW
WAGES TO BE PAID STUDENTS.
CALIFORNIA THREE ACCREDITED
PROGRAMS WERE CLOSER TO JERRY
AND HE'S RIGHT ABOUT A LOT OF
STUDENTS TO BE PAID TELL YOU
ABOUT THE MEDICINE STUDENTS
WILL NO LONGER QUALIFIED AGENTS
BY BY THE NUCLEAR MEDICINE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE VERY MUCH
ALIKE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY THREE THE
ENGINE WITH PUBLIC GALLERY
SINGLE PUBLIC HOURS. MOVED
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THE
KNOWN ROOM FORTY ADRE PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE. TWO WITNESSES
WHO WERETO TESTIFY IN A- TO S.
TO EIGHT TWELVE SEVENTY. NAME
OR EXIT AND ONLY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS DON HARMON I'M NOT
RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AT EL CAMINO COLLEGE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
FOR ALL THE THANK YOU HE THEN
STATUS THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
APOLOGIES FOR MISSING THE
SUPPORT WINDOW THIS IS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. YOU HAVE
TO GET. BEHIND THE WHEEL YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO ONLINE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ERICA
THANK ON BEHALF OF CORRELATION
THERAPY AND THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED. TO EIGHTY ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU EXCELLENT. NINE ONE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE PLEASE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION OKAY. MY
NAME IS ANITA COLLECTOR I AM.
THE TASK FORCE IN EARLY EMINM
POINT HERE YOU MIND CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH TO THE-REGULATORY ADVISORY GROUP ARE
TCC- AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL IN THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THANK YOU CREATED.
FREE ASIAN NASAL WHINE. IN
CALIFORNIA NEXT LINE. THE MOST
RECENT ON THE SEVENTY SEVEN. MY
NAME IS CHRISTY FOSTER BOWMAN
DAY TICKET DIRECTOR FOR
RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSING THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. MY TWO
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
BREANNA. I AM FROM AIR AND SEA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE.
EIGHTY ONE TWO SEVEN ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE. THANK YOU THAT'S
FINE. MY TWO FIFTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BARBARA PLEADING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE REGISTERED CONCERNS.
FOR EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
THANKS THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
EIGHT ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
RETURNED. TO THIRTEEN. ALL OF.
MY NAME IS SHANNON- I AM YEAH
OKAY I'M DIRECTOR FOR MODERN
TECHNOLOGY SCHOOL AND FOUND OUT
WHY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. MY TWO FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DORIS EVERY SAMMY I
AMBER PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
NORTHRIDGE AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE TWO SEVEN THREE
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE ONE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KRISTEN BUYING
SHOPLIFTING PROFESSOR AT
CALIFORNIA BAPTIST UNIVERSITY
AND ADJUNCT FACULTY AT CHEEKY
COLLEGE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. TWENTY TWO FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS RACHEL
CAMPBELL I'M THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR THE PROMOTE COLLEGE
RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE TWO SEVEN THREE THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NINE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KAREN
LAYING ON THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR
OF THE DIAGNOSTIC RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM AT THE
COLLEGE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SALE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
MY TWO FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS WILL HAPPEN
SO I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGIST AND THE
DIRECTOR OF MEDICAL RADIOGRAPHY
PROGRAM. AT ONE MORNING
DIVERSITY AND RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWELVE SYMMETRY THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE
ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
pDIRECTOR AT BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THE CURRENT
BILL AS IT IS WRITTEN THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE ONE OH FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KATHY
WILSON AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF MEDICAL DEBT THE
MATURITY AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO E. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NINE ONE OH FOUR
I'M SORRY. BY ONE OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS JAMIE ALLENDER
AND THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT
SANTA ROSA. JUNIOR COLLEGE AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE TWO SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS STEVE BARNETT I'M A
DRUG ADDICT INSTRUCTOR AT
CURRENT ACADEMY OF MEDICAL ARTS
AND I. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE
ONE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M JAN WENT ON
BEHALF OF THE JOINT REVIEW
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS IN NUCLEAR MEDICINE
TECHNOLOGY IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE TWO SEVEN THREE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
MY TWO FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JOSH- TO
GROUP THE RAIOLOGY SUPERVISOR
WITH ARROWHEAD REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY ONE TWO SEVEN THREE
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. MY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
BRENDA HANDING A RESPIRATORY
THERAPIST AND CURRENT PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF RESPIRATORY THERAPY
AT FOOTHILL COLLEGE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINETEEN
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO THIRTY
EIGHT YOU'RE GOING TO. HELLO
YES YOUR LINES OF NAME
MOTIVATION POSITION. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN.
HI THIS IS MONTANA FORMER
STUDENT OF ARROWHEAD REGIONAL
MEDICAL CENTER IN COLD
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
OPPOSE FROM EIGHTY ONE TO SEVEN
GREAT THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE
ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE BECAUSE
ROCK WHILE WE'RE THERE FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGE RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU YOUR NEXT
LINE. NINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS THAT TRICIA PETERS A
NUCLEAR MEDICINE TECHNOLOGIST
AND ALSO A DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTRATORI STRONGLY OPPOSE
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE TWO OH TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS R. S. Q. MERIT
THE X. RAY TECHNICIAN PROGRAM
DIRECTOR CANTON CLARKSON DENIES
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE
TWO SEVEN THREE THANK YOU SIGN.
BY TWO THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MIR
MANCHEGO AND EXECUTE AN
ARROWHEAD REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER SCHOOL OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGY WE'VE BEEN
GRADUATING HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS SINCE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB. ONE TWO SEVEN THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE TWO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
JOB. IT IS. LIKE TO TERMINATE.
HI THIS IS BERLIN RIGHT FROM
AARON THESE COUPLE OF
RADIOLOGIC THANK. I OPPOSE
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE TO
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS ON ANY
SITE AREA AND SEE- RED STICKING
UP OKAY. NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN THE MORNING PHOTO PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AT JD COLLEGE
RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM
AND WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JAMES MORROW I'M THE EXECUTIVE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGY AND THE CAMPUS
DIRECTOR AT GARNOCK ACADEMY OF
MEDICAL LARKIN BANAI WE ARE
VERY STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AB ONE TWO SEVEN THREE
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE ONE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
STEVE RODRIGUEZ- WITH THE
ARROWHEAD REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE TWO
OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DR
NICOLE WALTER HERE ON THE
DIDACTIC INSTRUCTOR WITH
GARNOCK ACADEMY OF MAGICAL ARTS
IN VAN NUYS CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGIST
COMPUTED TOMOGRAPHY HIRSCH.
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO TWO EIGHT
ONE TWO SEVEN THREE THANK YOU
NECKLINE. NINE ONE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE EIGHTY YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING
ON TO LINE ONE THIRTY THREE
LINE ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN
YOU BALD A CLINICAL COORDINATOR
OF LA COUNTY HARBOR. CENTER OUR
PROGRAM OPPOSES AB ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
MY TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
KATIE NEAL THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NUCLEAR
MEDICINE TECHNOLOGY
CERTIFICATION GORE AND I'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS THE NMTCBEES
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR FREE
NASA I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
MEDICAL IMAGING AT TEXAS
COLLEGE. AND WE STRONGLY BUT
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE- BELIEVE
BILL OF A. B. ONE TWO SEVEN
THREE I THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE TO FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DR CHERYL YOUNG I'M THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT NATIONAL
UNIVERSITY FOR RADIATION
THERAPY I'M ALSO A PRACTICING
RADIATION THERAPISTS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AB TWELVE
THIRTY THREE AM THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. TWENTY TWO OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH IT WILL BE NO REAL FORMER
RADIOLOGY DEPARTMENT MANAGER
CRITICAL HOSPITAL VOICING MY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET BY
WITH THE DOCTOR MARK TOMORROW
PROGRAM DIRECTOR RADIOLOGIC
SCIENCES AT CALIFORNIA BAPTIST
UNIVERSITY AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE TWO SEVEN THREE.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE TWO
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
CURRICULUM READ TECH STUDENT
ERICA AT REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE FARMERS IN REGIONAL
MEDICAL CENTER. THE ONE SEVEN
THREE THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE
TWO OH FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO- FOR
YOU MAYBE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE. NINE TO NINE TO
SIXTY SIX TO SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS LAWRENCE JACKSON
PROGRAM DIRECTOR AND ACADEMIC
CENTER PUT ORANGE COAST COLLEGE
BIGGER STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. ONE TWO SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS WILLIAM
MORGAN AND I'M THE CHAIR THE
RADIOLOGICAL THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT IN THE INTERIM
PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF THE
DIAGNOSTIC MEDICAL IMAGING
PROGRAM AT CITY COLLEGE OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE NEXT HONESTLY
OPPOSE AB CALL THAT BE GREAT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS LESLIE AND MAN I AM A
CURRENT RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS AND THE CLINICAL
COORDINATOR WORKING ON THE
COLLEGE RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY
PROGRAM I AM STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE
TWO TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS AND YOUR CARD THING-
FORMER STUDENT OF THEIR HEAD
REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER SCHOOL
OF RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY. AND
I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL AP ONE TWO SEVEN
THREE THANK YOU NICE LINE. ONE
ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARCH
PROBLEM I'M A T. T.
TECHNOLOGIES AT OUR RADIOLOGY
TECHNOLOGIST EXCLUSIVE MEDICAL
CENTER- THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR
THANK YOU FOR THAT YOU NEED TO
COLLEGE RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY
PROGRAM AND I OPPOSE AB ONE TWO
SPECIALLY. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS HOPE CASTRO THE RESPIRATORY
THERAPIST PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
PIMA MEDICAL INSTITUTE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET THAT
THE LINE NUMBER. THE NEXT LINE
IS THE LAST LINE IN THE COMMENT
YOU SHOULD BE JUST A MOMENT.
NINE TO SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE DID HAVE
ANOTHER LINE QUEUE UP. MY TWO
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES MY NAME
IS CHARLENE PURELY ON THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
LIMITED X. P. PROGRAM HERE AT
GRAND CANYON NINE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. AB ONE TWO SEVEN THREE.
OKAY THANK YOU BUT THAT WE'VE
TAKEN FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR HOW MANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL PEOPLE ARE
WAITING. TO OKAY SO WELL VERY
RAPIDLY WILL DO THAT TOO AND
THEN IF THERE'S ANY ONE ELSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY ON THIS
BILL EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU CAN ENTER YOUR
TESTIMONY AT THE- COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH CENTRE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH WEBSITE SO WE'LL TAKE
THE LAST TWO AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO- THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS. NINE ONE SEVENTEEN
ONE MOMENT PLEASE NINE ONE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
MY NAME IS BRUCE ODA DEPARTMENT
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
RADIOLOGY PROGRAM AT SANTA
BARBARA CITY COLLEGE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE TWO SEVEN THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
NINE ONE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JED MILES I'M CLINICAL
COORDINATOR AT PIMA MEDICAL
INSTITUTE RADIOGRAPHY PROGRAM
AND I OPPOSE THE B. ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN THREE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THANK YOU MODERATOR- AND- WILL
NOW BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE
AND AGAIN IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE WHO THEN JOINED ON
AFTERWARDS PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH WEBSITE. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- CENTER RAS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO THE- PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN THE TESTIMONY I'M-
BUT I'M CERTAINLY A SUPPORTER
OF EARN AND LEARN PARTICULARLY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE HEALTHCARE
FIELD AND PARTICULARLY GIVEN
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR STATE I
AM SOMEWHAT CONCERNED THOUGH AS
TO WHETHER WE REALLY HAVE A
HANDLE ON THE- SCHOOLS. THE
STUDENTS IN THE OCCUPATIONS
THAT MAY BE ADVERSELY IMPACTED.
BY THE CONTENT OF THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE HEARD FROM A
LOT OF THE FOLKS IN THE
RADIOLOGY FEELS NUCLEAR
MEDICINE AND THE LIKE. BUT FOR
EXAMPLE IF A IF AN ACCREDITING
BODY. DOES NOT PERMIT EARN AND
LEARN IF THE ACCREDITING BODY
PERHAPS IS THE ONLY ACCREDITING
BODY IN THE NATION THAT
ACCREDITS SCHOOLS AND THERE ARE
AT LEAST A FEW OF THOSE IDEAS
AS I RECALL PHYSICIANS
ASSISTANTS FOR EXAMPLE. AT
LEAST AT ONE POINT IN TIME HAD
ONE ACCREDITING BODY IN THE- IN
THE COUNTRY. IN SCHOOLS AND
STUDENTS DEPEND ON
ACCREDITATION IN ORDER TO
GRADUATE AND TO GET JOBS AND
CERTAINLY WELL PERHAPS THEY MAY
BE WORKING BE ABLE TO WORK IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO HAVE THE SORT OF
MOBILITY THAT THEY FULLY EXPECT
TO HAVE. WHEN THEY PAY THE
MONEY THAT SOME OF THEM PAY TO
GO TO SOME OF THESE SCHOOLS AND
OBTAIN. THE CREDENTIALS. SO I'M
BOTH I JUST SAID I'M GOOD I'M
CONCERNED SO I GUESS I HAVE
HAVING MADE THAT COMMENT I HAVE
A I HAVE A QUESTION. OF THE
AUTHOR IF YOU WILL ACCEPT IT
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT ASKING
IN ADVANCE. THESE THANK YOU MR
SO IF- IF THE PARTICULAR
ACCREDITING BODY DOES NOT
PERMIT EARN AND LEARN. IF IT'S
THE ONLY ACCREDITING BODY THAT
ACCREDITS PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND IF THE
ACCREDITING BODY HAPPENS TO BE
OUTSIDE THE JURISDICTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE IN
THE LAWS THAT WE PASS HERE.
WHAT'S THE SOLUTION AND WHAT'S
THE IMPACT OF ON CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
WELL THAT'S SOMETHING I CAN
DEFINITELY LOOK AT WITH- THE
SPONSORS AS WELL OBVIOUSLY THAT
THE OPPOSITION THAT CAME IN AS
WE SPOKE. FOR FIFTEEN MINUTES-
THAT CAME IN LATE JUST RECENTLY
SEVEN REALLY BEEN ABLE TO
ADDRESS THEIR ISSUES AND
CONCERNS BUT DEFINITELY WAITING
TO HEAR BACK FROM THEM I HAVE-
REACHED OUT TO ME AS WELL SINCE
I JUST SORT OF THEIR
OPPOSITION. SO AS SOON AS I GET
ARE IN WRITING BACK FROM THEM I
LOOK AT DRESSING THEIR ISSUES
OBVIOUSLY THIS COULD BE A
COMPLICATION WITH SOME OF THESE
AGENCIES BUT DEFINITELY I'M I'M
WILLING TO WORK WITH THEM TO
SEE WHAT YOUR FOLKS IN A BETTER
PLACE. I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES IS- SOME OF
THESE FOLKS BELIEVE THAT- THIS
BILLMANDATES PAYMENTS TO
STUDENTS WHICH IT DOES NOT IT
SIMPLY EASES RESTRICTIONS THAT
CURRENTLY. DO NOT ALLOW
STUDENTS TO EARN MONEY. FOR THE
FREE WORK THEY'RE DOING. TWENTY
FIVE MISTER JUST ANOTHER. OR
TWO. PLEASE THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR LOOKING INTO THIS
I'M JUST NOT SURE THAT WE CAN
IMPACT. NECESSARILY IF THE
ACCREDITING BODY IS LOCATED IN
NORTH CAROLINA OR GEORGIA OR
CHICAGO WHEN WE- SAY THE
ACCREDITING BODIES MAY NOT.
RESTRICT EARN AND LEARN I DON'T
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY ANY
ATTENTION TO US AND THEN IF
THAT'S THE BODY THAT ACCREDITS
THE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS TO THE-
SCHOOL IF THE ACCREDITING BODY
DECIDES NOT TO ACCREDIT THE
SCHOOL. AND THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING IN IT. DO WE
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE HAVING. KNOWN
MY CURRENT ASSIGNMENT I DABBLE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AND THE VERS BOARDS AND
BUREAUS THAT. FALL UNDER THAT
DO WE KNOW HOW MANY OF THE
BOARDS AND BUREAUS IN THE-
PROGRAMS THAT ARE LICENSED BY
THOSE BOARDS AND BUREAUS HOW
MANY OF THEM. HAVE EARN AND
LEARN- RESTRICTIONS AND HOW
MANY. OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
ACCREDITED BY. THE BODIES OR
ENTITIES OR AGENCIES THAT
PROHIBIT EARN AND LEARN. IF I
MAY I KNOW- BACK IN- TWENTY
SIXTEEN MY A. B. TWENTY ONE OH
FIVE WITH SIX POINT THE ISSUE I
BELIEVE ABOUT LEISURE FREE
STILL ON HE COULD PROBABLY
GOING TO BE MORE DETAIL ON THAT
IF IT'S POSSIBLE YES CAN
REBUILD PLEASE BRING BACK MATT
LUCE FROM S. YEAH YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON- JANITORS AND CHAIR
TWO REGARDING THE TCA THAT
PRIMARILY THE RESPIRATORY
THERAPY- BOARD RESTRICTS
AIRPORT- BUT I THINK IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT-
IN TERMS OF THE RAD TAX WHICH
FALLS UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. WHEN WE WERE IN
DISCUSSION WITH DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THE ACTION DO NOT
REQUIRE PROGRAMS TO BE
ACCREDITED BY ADAM G. R.
CERTAIN CALIFORNIA SO IN TERMS
OF- PROGRAM STILL BEING ABLE TO
GRADUATE STUDENTS OR NOT THEY
WOULD STILL BE ABLE TO GRADUATE
AND STUDENTS WOULD STILL BE
ABLE TO BE ABLE TO GET THEIR
LICENSE IN CALIFORNIA PRACTICE
WITHIN CALIFORNIA. THE REAL
ISSUE AND BROUGHT THAT COMES
WITH THE ABILITY TO ACCESS THAT
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION WHICH-
THAT CUTTING BODY COULD SIMPLY
UPDATE THEIR STANDARDS- TO
ALLOW EARNING MORE PROGRAMS.
AND WOULD COME INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH THE BILL. WELL MR I. AM
NOT SURE I AGREE WITH THAT DID
YOU JUST SAY THAT PROGRAMS.
FALL THAT FALL UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
DO NOT NEED TO BE ACCREDITED WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT THE NURSING PROGRAMS AND
ACCREDITATION AND VOCATIONAL
NURSING PROGRAMS AND
ACCREDITATION. I HAVE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH A PHYSICIAN'S
ASSISTANT PROGRAM THAT COULD
NOT RETAIN ITS ACCREDITATION
BECAUSE THEPROGRAM OR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COULD NOT
OFFER A MASTER'S DEGREE. SO I
WANNA MAKE SURE. I'M CLEAR I
WILL STOP MY QUESTIONS AT THIS
POINT MISTER CHAIR AFTER I GET
A RESPONSE I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TO MOVE IT OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE BUT I HAVE VERY
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPACT. ONE HEALTH CARE
TRAINING PROGRAMS AT LEAST
UNTIL I GET A HANDLE ON HOW
MANY THERE ARE. AND WHAT THE
ALTERNATIVES ARE. WITH
RESPECTED ACCREDITATION BUT I
WOULD LIKE A RESPONSE TO MY
QUESTION. SO- DECEMBER
ACTUALLY- I WILL TELL YOU THAT
WHEN WE WHEN THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE STAFF LOOKED AT THE
BILL BECAUSE I THINK THE VERY
QUESTION YOU RAISE IS ONE THAT
WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT AS
WELL- THE WAY THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL IS PHRASED AND AGAIN
OBVIOUSLY THE SPONSORS OR THE
AUTHOR- SAM WRONG PLEASE TELL
ME- BUT WHEN WE LOOKED AT THAT-
IT FOR EXAMPLE IT SAYS THAT
THE- DC AIRFARES BOARDS FROM
PROHIBITS THEM FROM-
PROHIBITING APPROVING
ACCREDITING PRO PROGRAM. BUT
IT'S THE DATE THE A AND C. P.
H. AS WELL THAT THE USUALLY THE
BOARD ITSELF IS LICENSING THE
INDIVIDUAL AND NOT THE TRAINING
PROGRAM SO IN SOME SENSE IS
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS IN
TERMS OF GIVEN THE WAY THE
LANGUAGE IS PHRASED IN THE
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD NOT
DIRECTLY- THAT. THE CDPH
CERTAINLY AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
RADIATION- FOLKS- AS AT THAT
DATE WERE TESTIFYING AS WELL
AS- DCA. AND THAT THEY WOULD
NOT NECESSARILY- BE DIRECTLY-
BECAUSE THE BLADECENTER'S ABOUT
THE INDIVIDUAL AND NOT PROGRAM
THAT- THERE ARE SOME LIMITS TO
HOW MUCH THE- THAT IMPACTED
ACTUALLY HAS ON THE BODY'S
ACTUALLY CREDIT. CREDIT THE
ACTUAL TRAINING PROGRAM ITSELF
WHAT YES MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU
ARE YOU MAY BE MORE OF AN
EXTRANET AND I KNOW BUT I WILL
MISS YOU IF I MAY I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THAT. MIGHT AT
LEAST WITH SOME PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE PROGRAM THAT I
HAVE TO REPORT TO HER IF YOU'RE
NOT A GRADUATE FROM AN
ACCREDITED SCHOOL. RIGHT YOUR
MOBILITY TO THE EXTENT YOU WERE
ABLE TO GET A LICENSE IS
SEVERELY LIMITED. AND I THINK
WE SHOULD AT LEAST BE AWARE OF
THAT AND I WOULD ASK THE AUTHOR
TO CHECK ON THAT BEFORE THE
BILL COMES UP ON THE FLOOR
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
SERRA OFFICER AGNES. YEAH I
WOULD LIKE TO TOUCH IT SO MY
COMMENTS WITH SENATOR RAWSON
JUSTICE UP ALSO SOMEBODY WHO.
HOLDS A LICENSE THAT HAD TO
HAVE. GRADUATE OF AN ACCREDITED
SCHOOL OF MAKES ME SOMEWHAT
NERVOUS ESPECIALLY SINCE SOME
OF THE- OPPOSITION AND I
UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION WAS
LATE ENOUGH OR- SOMETHING IS
COMMITTED TO. CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT THIS BUT- UP ALL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT
I'M ALSO CONCERNED THAT. SOME
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CALLING
INTO OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WILL WHO ARE OFTEN SOME OF THE
ONLY. PEOPLE WILL PROVIDE THIS
KIND OF EDUCATION AND SOME OF
OUR- AT. NINETY COMMITTEES
WROTE. THANK YOU MR TEAR AND I
DO APOLOGIZE BOUNCING BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN COMMITTEES I DO
HAVE. A BASICALLY THE SAME COME
A CONCERN THAT SENATOR ROTH HAS
BEEN ON A DIFFERENT LEVEL- I
THINK IT STANDS WITH
RECRUITMENT IF SOME PROGRAMS
ARE. ELIGIBLE TO- PAY FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO GO THROUGH THE
CLINICAL PORTION OF THEIR
STUDIES. I THINK. A LARGE
PORTION OF THE POPULATION AND
THE DOES RECRUITMENT TRAINING
LIKE A CLLEGE IS IN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS- YOU KNOW BIG. BIG SHOW
COLLEGE FOR INSTANCE LIKE MANY
OF THE COLLEGES THAT CALLED IN
AS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
BECAUSE OF BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE%
PROGRAM DOESN'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO PAY PEOPLE TO GO
THROUGH THIS RECRUITMENT PART
OR THIS. TRAINING PROGRAM FOR
THE CLINICAL PORTION. WHEN
THEY'RE INTERNING AT THE
HOSPITALS BECAUSE THEY DO- MY
DAUGHTER IS A NURSE BUT THEY
DID TESTING AND TRAINING AT THE
SCHOOL AND THEN THEY DID
CLINICAL PORTIONS OF THE
HOSPITAL IF THEY CAN'T PAY FOR
THEM TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL. OR
THE EMPLOYER OR THE BENEFITING
PERSON DOESN'T- ORGANIZATION
DOESN'T PAY FOR THEM. THEN THEY
COULD GO TO A DIFFERENT PROGRAM
AND BECAUSE THEY'RE FREE TO DO
THAT AND IT WOULD BE YOU KNOW
THEIR CHOICE TO GO TO A PROGRAM
THAT PAID THEM TO GO THROUGH
SOME OF THE TRAINING- TO LEARN.
IN SO I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
WAGE ALLIES I KNOW THE BILL- I
GUESS I SHOULD ASK THE AUTHOR.
THE BILL DOESN'T MANDATE
PAYMENT- FOR CLINICALS RIGHT-
INTERNS OKAY THERE'S NO MANDATE
FOR PAYMENT AND I THINK THE
CONCERN IS THAT. IF YOU KNOW
HOW STATE CAN AFFORD TO PAY FOR
THEIR INTERNS TO HAVE CLINICALS
N. B. C. PLANT. OR MERCED CAN'T
BUT ANOTHER COLLEGE CAN I THINK
THAT'S WHERE THE ROAD IS GOING
TO BE IN IT WOULD BE CONSISTENT
SO- IDEA AND- I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL IN THAT
CASE BUT I JUST THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING THE QUESTION IT. IT'S
NOT MANDATED BUT I THINK IT
LIES IN THE RECRUITING PIECE-
FOR CLASSES TO CONTINUE AND IT
AFFECTS. THE COLLEGE IS
DIFFERENT IF THEY CAN'T AFFORD
AND TO PAY FOR THE CLINICALS-
IN THE INTERNSHIP PROCESS THANK
YOU SIR FOR LETTING ME ASK
QUESTIONS OF COURSE. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- RUBIO.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND- I DON'T
WANT TO BELABOR THE POINT BUT
CLEARLY THIS ROBUST IMPORTANT
DEBATE HAS CREATED SOME-QUESTIONS THAT- AND I
UNDERSTAND THOUGH THE LATE
OPPOSITION SOMETIMES REALLY
DIFFICULT TO ADDRESS- WHEN IT
COMES TO SLATE AND ALSO AS A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE IT'S
DIFFICULT TO. TO TACKLE THESE
ISSUES AND AGAIN I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE OPTED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS AND REALLY GO
DEEP AND ANSWER SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS ARE LEFT UNANSWERED
AND I WILL ALSO SUPPORT THE
BILL BUT WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT THESE QUESTIONS AND ISSUES
WILL BE ADDRESSED BEFORE
FOURTEEN KIA. THANK YOU A
CERTAIN AMOUNT THANK YOU
ANYTHING HERE YOU'RE SEEING A
PATTERN HERE OF A KIND OF
COMING IN FEELING REALLY
CONFIDENT AND THEN SWING WE
WAIT WAIT. WHAT'S HAPPENING- IN
AS SOMEONE WHO DID HAVE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CALL AND- MY
QUESTION IS. YOU CAN YOU JUST
PLEASE CLARIFY IT WHERE THE
FUNDING IS SUPPOSED TO COME
FROM- IS IT THE ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS IS THERE GOING TO
BE- A PRIVATE PUBLIC
OPPORTUNITY IS ALL OF THE ABOVE
NOTHING SPECIFIED- AND I GUESS.
I AM THINKING ALONG THE LINES
THAT. IF THEIR FUNDING ISN'T
THERE HOW DOES THAT IMPACT THE
PROGRAM THE EXPERIENCE AND THE
TRAINING- IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
PAIN BUT YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE-
WHAT'S THE FALLOUT OF NOT
HAVING SOME OF THIS- AND
CERTAINLY THE ACCREDITATION
PIECES HAS BEEN MENTIONED- IS
ALSO. SOMETHING THAT'S ON MY
MIND. IT DEFINITELY GET IT OVER
WITH THE LATE OPPOSITION TO A
LOT OF QUESTIONS CAME SO I
REALLY CAN'T ANSWER A LOT OF
THEM. HAVE DEFINITELY LOOK INTO
IT AND- MAYBE DIFFERENT AMOUNT
AGAIN WOULD YOU HAVE ANYTHING
TO KIND OF HELP WITH SOME OF
THIS DISCUSSION AND CONCERN FOR
HAVING THAT. YOU HAVE TO GET
BETTER OKAY THE CHAIR. YES
PLEASE DO. YEP AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION BETTER.
I WOULD I WOULD JUST RESPOND BY
SAYING THAT THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT FOR PAYMENT OR
FUNDING TO HAPPEN IN THIS CASE
THIS IS JUST REALLY ENSURING
THAT IT THE PROGRAM. AND WOULD
LIKE TO CREATE A- PROGRAM THAT
YOU CAN DO SO I'M IN ASKING OUR
STATE LICENSING STANDARDS TO
ALIGN WITH THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. I'M WAITING- IT'S NOT A-
IT'S NOT A BIG TO THE CREATION
OF RUNNING PROGRAMS. NO
REQUIREMENT ON FUNDING- DID NOT
REQUIRING SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE.
WAGES OR ANYONE TO PROVIDE
REACHES FOR PAYMENT. SO I GUESS
IF I IF I MAY THROUGH THE CHAIR
AND I UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT I GUESS I'M
THINKING WELL WHAT WAS THE IDEA
LIKE WHERE IS THIS GOING TO
COME FROM IS IT POTENTIALLY
FROM THE ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
AND SO. YOU KNOW I'M GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY I
THINK THAT- THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF COMMENTS THAT ARE
BROUGHT UP AND I ALSO
ENCOURAGE. THE OPPOSITION TO
HELP US BETTER UNDERSTAND SOME
OF THIS BECAUSE I THINK
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
BUT I'M NOT SURE WE'VE GOTTEN
SOME OF THE ANSWERS ON EITHER
SIDE- TO HELP US UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT WILL REALLY LOOK LIKE
ONCE IT'S BEING- IMPLEMENTED BY
THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO IMPLEMENT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS. SO BUT IT
BUT IT'S BEEN A ROBUST AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. OKAY SAYING NINE
ACTUALLY I DO HAVE A QUESTION I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY- SOMEBODY
ELSE ACTUALLY POSE THIS TO- TO-
MATT LUCE BUT THIS YEAR I USE
SO WE DO HAVE FOR EXAMPLE YOU
KNOW WE HAVE OPPONENTS- WHO FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S THIS JOINT
REVIEW COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
RADIATION RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGY
J. OR SEARCH OUT THERE SHE
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION THEY DO
HAVE AN ACCREDITATION
REQUIREMENT. ACTUALLY FOR BIDS-
STUDENTS RUNNING WAGES FOR
CLINICAL HOURS OR- SO WOULDN'T
BILL DOES IS LIKE I WANNA KNOW
WHAT YOUR INTENTIONS ARE SO
WITH THIS BILL BASED ON YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT YOUR
INTENTIONS OF THE SPELLS A
SPONSOR. FOR BID- PROGRAMS-
DEREK CREDITED BASICALLY J. J.
R. SIR ACCREDITED PROGRAMS FROM
OPERATING HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THAT I WOULD JUST
RESPOND BY THIS IS ACTUALLY A
REAL REQUIREMENT ON OUR
LICENSING BOARDS WERE THE
GATEKEEPERS FOR THESE PROGRAMS
FOR THEM TO UPDATE THE
STANDARDS AND USE ACCREDITING
BODIES BACK ALLOW EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS. OKAY BUT IT
DIDN'T QUITE ANSWER MY QUESTION
MY QUESTION IS THAT OKAY THE-
THE BODY I THINK IT'S C. PH
ACTUALLY ACCEPTS- WITH THIS IS
INTENTION IS BILLED TO SAY
BECAUSE THIS MAY BE I THINK IT
MAY BE I'M NOT SURE FOR SURE
AND MAYBE THE ONLY CREDITING
BODY FOR- FOR. THESE RADIOLOGY
THAT THESE TECHNICIANS
RADIOLOGICAL TECHNICIANS WOULD
FOR BID. C. P. H. FROM
RECOGNIZING GRADUATES. OF
PROGRAMS ARE ACCREDITED BY
JERRY BY JAY ARE SERVED. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION IT IT
WOULD. BE J. R. SERV MAINTAIN.
THEIR PROHIBITION AGAINST OUR
OWN LEARN IF WOULD ASK THEM TO-
IT WOULD NOT THEY WOULD NOT USE
THAT CREDIT CARD. BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
CITY CALIFORNIA FOR RAT PACKS
RECOGNIZES PROGRAMS- IN
RECOGNIZES GRADUATES THAT- ARE
ABLE TO GRADUATE COMPONENT EVEN
IF IT DOESN'T HAVE THE G. R.
CERTIFICATION SO WHEN TALKING
TO. THAT DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE THEY DO NOT HAVE A
ON THE BILL BECAUSE HEALTHCARE
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
GRADUATE RIGHT TAX- THEY WOULD
STILL RECOGNIZE AND BE ABLE TO
GET THEIR LICENSE. THE WHOLE
WITHIN OUR INTENTION IS THAT WE
WOULD REMOVE BARRIERS EARNING
MONEY PROGRAMS AND- IN.
ORGANIZATIONS UPDATE THEIR
STANDARDS RECOGNIZED THIS NEW
MODEL. OKAY ALL RIGHT. NOW I'VE
MET THAT WHEN I WAS TALKING TO
THE STAFF THE NOW AT LEAST WE
WERE DISCUSSING IT. AT THE
LEAST THE LANGUAGE DIDN'T
APPEAR THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY
WHAT WOULD ACTUALLY HAPPEN WITH
THE BILL THAT WAS PASSED- BUT
IT IS HELPFUL FOR ME TO HEAR
FROM YOU WHAT YOUR INTENTIONS
ARE. IN RELATION TO DEVELOP I
THINK YOU HEAR THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS OF THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
WHAT WOULD RESULT I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THE GOAL. OF TRYING TO
NOT DISCOURAGE EARN AND LEARN-
BUT- AND- BUT I THINK THERE ARE
THERE ARE GONNA BE SOMETHING
THAT THE CONCERNS ARE BEING
RAISED THAT- THERE'S ISSUES
RELATED TO- YEAH. ACTUALLY THE
PIPELINES AND STANDARDS FOR US.
FOR VARIOUS HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS I DO KNOW THAT
SIR LEYVA HAS HER MICROPHONE UP
SO- I WILL. MOVE IT TO HER BUT
I DO HAVE SOME OTHER ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS AS WELL SO THEIR
LABOR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WON THE ECHO LL THE
COMMENTS MADE FROM YOURSELF AND
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL TODAY BUT I TOO
WILL BE HOPING SOMEBODY TO
ISSUES CAN BE ADDRESSED. AND IF
IT GETS TO THE FLOOR THEY WILL
BE ADDRESSED AND I CAN STILL
SUPPORT THE BILL OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA- THE AND- THE
OTHER QUESTION I DO HAVE- IN A
BIG DOSE OF THE COMMITTEE SAYS
OUR LAST BILL TO- FOR. SO I USE
THIS ACTUALLY SAT ON THE BOARD
AND ACCREDITATION BODY SO I SAT
ON IT HEALTH CARE ACCREDITATION
NO HEALTH EDUCATOR- PREDATION
BODY. AND ONE OF THE THINGS FOR
AN ACCREDITATION BODY FOR THE
GOVERNMENT RECOGNIZES THAT WE
DON'T. GAUGE IN ANTI
COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR- THAT THE
STAN. ARE PURELY- EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS. SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION I POSE TO J. CERT- SO
WE HAVE THE CLG SORT OF
TESTIFIED. YOU KNOW I HEARD
THAT YOU SAID THE RATIONALE FOR
BIDDING- STUDENTS BRAVING RAGES
IN CLINICAL HOURS TWO INCH TO
WAS TO QUOTE INSURE THEY'RE NOT
USED TO REPLACE QUALIFIED
STAFF. WHICH SOUNDS ANTI
COMPETITIVE CAN YOU JUSTIFY WHY
THAT REQUIREMENTS IN EXISTENCE
I REALIZE THAT THAT'S A BIT
SEPARATE FROM THE BILL. BUT I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. WHAT
WAS THE QUESTION THE QUESTION
IS WHY THAT REQUIREMENT IS AN
EDUCATIONAL STANDARD AND IT'S
NOT ANTI COMPETITIVE. THE
STANDARD DATA YOU ARE PROVIDING
IDEAS FROM EARNING WAGES FOR
CLINICAL HOURS AND ASSIGNMENTS
THAT PROHIBITION DOES NOT HOW
DOES THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE
QUALITY PROGRAMS ARE ENSURING
THAT- THE STUDENTS ARE MEETING
STANDARD EXACT. REPEAT
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS NOT.
HELLO HELLO YES SO I GUESS
THAT'S- MISS- LET'S SEE WINTER
PLEASE. HI SO THE STUDENTS ARE
STUDENTS AND THEY'RE NOT
CLINICALLY COMPETENT. ON MANY
CORCORAN SUPERVISED YOU SURE
THEY'RE NOT TAKING A DIG. HIGHS
IN POSITIONS THAT COULD
COMPROMISE THEN YOU. OKAY THEY
CAN BE STUDENTS AND RECEIVE HEY
BUT- I DON'T SEE HOW THAT HAS
TO DO WITH NO THEY CANNOT I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT. WELL THEY THEY ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE STANDARD YOU PUT
IN PLACE NOT BECAUSE- THE
ANOTHER IT'S A SUPERVISION
STANDARD IS ABOUT EDUCATIONAL
QUALITY. I'M NOT SURE WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING US TO DO WITH
THAT. EDUCATIONAL QUALITY
INSURERS THAT WE'RE DELIVERING
IONIZING RADIATION THANKS FOR
SHARING. QUALITY PATIENT CARE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER- THERE
MIGHT BE SOME OTHER PEOPLE WANT
TO ASK FOR THE QUESTION THAT-
OKAY- ALL RIGHT WELL WITH THAT-
I THINK THAT- SEMI RODRIGUEZ I
THINK YOU HEAR THERE ARE SOME
OPEN QUESTIONS- THAT- NEED TO
BE WORKED ON- I THINK ARE YOU
KNOW- WE CAN TRY TO WORK ON
SOME OF THEM IS- IN THIS
COMMITTEE- BUT I THINK THAT
SOME OTHER ONES ARE ALSO OPEN.
SO HOPEFULLY YOU CAN TRY TO
WORK THAT OUT- WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE IS THE OPPOSITION BUT
ALSO TO ENSURING THAT WE'RE NOT
CREATING A ALTERNATE PROBLEM I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS YOU'RE
TRYING TO CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY FROM DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS WHO- ALSO THAT WHO
WHO MAY ALSO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO GO
ESSENTIALLY WITHOUT PAY- OR
HAVE TO COMPLETE MORE LOANS- IF
ESPECIALLY IF THERE ARE PEOPLE
WILLING TO STEP UP AND PROVIDE
WHILE THERE IS WHILE THEY'RE
LEARNING- AND- PROVIDING- YELP
CLINICAL SERVICES UNDER
SUPERVISION UNDER AN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM SO I THINK
THAT'S A WORTHY GOAL- BUT I
ALSO THINK THERE ARE SOME
CONCERTS SERMONS ABOUT THE WAY
THE BILLS FRAME TO CLARIFY THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ESSENTIALLY DENYING PEOPLE ALSO
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE OF CONFLICTS WITH
ACCREDITATION- AS. WELL SO WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YOU THANK YOU WILL- YOUR VOICES
MESSAGES BEEN. I WORK OTHER
SPONSORED A LOT OF THE ISSUES
AND CONCERNS ARE BROUGHT TODAY.
HI KNOWN SOONER I WOULD'VE BEEN
HAVING A LOT MORE ANSWERS FOR
YOU. BOTH THAT I RESPECT US
FROM MY BILL THING OKAY THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH- IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. THE MOVE BY
SERA OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ROB THE MOTIONS TO PASS
THE FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CAN I. CAN I'M MELINDA'S EGGMAN.
TAKE I CAN FALL. THEMSELVES I
GROW. HER TADO I FOR TITLE III
LLEVA FIVE LEAVE EILEEN MOON HI
THE MOON I ROTH. ROTH IRA RUBIO
HI RUBIO I WINNER FIVE WINNER I.
SO THE CURRENT ROLES NINE ZERO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
START MISSING MEMBER OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT-
LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
THREE BY SOMEONE IN THIS AREA-
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT TO EIGHTY SIX
NINETEEN BY SUMMER CALDERON I'M
NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SIX SIX SIX
BY SUMMER TWO. I'M NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE BUT
SOME RIVER LOW AND I'M NUMBER
ELEVEN EIGHTY TEN FIFTY ONE BY
SUMMER BENNETT IS THERE A
MOTION THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
GROVE- CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAND HI CAN I MELINDA'S AIKMAN.
AIKMAN I CAN SOLACE AND SO IF I
GROW HI GROUP HI HER TADO TOTO
I LEAVE A LEAVE I LEE MOON. THE
MOON I ROTH ROTH IRA RUBIO
RUBIO. I WINNER. WINNER I. OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO THEY COULD OCCUR
ROLE IN THE CAN TEN ZERO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN. ALRIGHT LET'S
NOW BEGIN TO LIFT THE CALLS
FOR- WILL BEGIN WITH THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FORTY FIVE OF
A SEMI REGULAR CURRY- CANCELED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS. HER TADO HI FOR TITLE
I LLEVA. LABOR EILEEN MOON. THE
MOON I. K. THAT BILL IS OUT
ELEVEN ZERO. LET'S MOVE NOW TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY SEVENTY
THREE BY SOME MEMBER ROBERT
READ THIS CONSOLE THESE CALL
THE ROLE OF ABSENT MEMBERS
CONSULTANTS. HI CONSOLES I HER
TADO FOR TITLE II LIMA TONIGHT
AS THE MOON AND CALLS OPEN FOR.
THAT LED TO DO IT RIGHT- EIGHTY
SEVENTY THREE IS OUT ELEVEN
ZERO LET'S MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY NINE
BY SOME MEMBER MAYOR SU CHI-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN A MAN
I GROW. I'M SORRY HE'S. SEVENTY
NINE. YEAH AND NOBODY. OF
CENTER GROVE I DO NOT OKAY OUR-
HER TADO HI HURTADO I. LLEVA
LABOR I RUBIO. RUBIO I. RIGHT
THE BILLS OUT TEN ZERO NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY BY SOME MEMBER REINA
GONZALEZ- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THAT'S NUMBERS
GROW. HER TADO ARM FOR TOTAL. I
LIVE A LIVE I. STEP THOSE OUT
TEN ZERO- NEXUS ITEM NUMBER
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN BY
SUMMER SANTIAGO- CANCELED THESE
CALL THE ROLE THAT SOME MEMBERS
OF LINDA'S. GROVE NO GROUP NO
HER TADO HI FOR TOTAL I LIVE A-
LIVE I. AT THE END OF. UHHUH
OKAY OKAY SO WHAT BETTER PLACE
OKAY RIGHT THE CURRENT ROLE IS-
NINE ONE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN- TEXAS OR ITEM NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY BY SOME
MEMBERS SANTIAGO- CONSOLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS HAND HI CAN I MELINDA'S
GROVE. HER TADO HIGH POTATO HI
GROSS NO THIS IS EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY NO
GROWTH NO. FOUR NINE ONE OKAY
THE CURRENT ROLE IS NINE NO ONE
AND WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. X.
ITEM IS. IDM NUMBER TWELVE
EIGHTY TWELVE HUNDRED BY SOME
MEMBER TANG- CANCELED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELINDA'S BOROUGH NO GROVE
KNOWN HER TADO. TOTO FIVE
WINNERS. IT WOULD BE TWELVE
HUNDRED TWELVE HUNDRED HITTING
HI. WINNER I. OKAY RIGHT ONE OF
THE CURRENT ROLE IS NINE ONE
WITH ALL THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THEN
FINALLY WE HAVE I- I NUMBER
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE BY SUMMER ROD REGUS I
CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT SOME MEMBERS. GROVE NOT
VOTING. AT MELINDA'S OKAY SO
THAT'S CURRENTLY NINE ZERO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE APPS AND
NUMBER. OKAY.
OKAY SO WE'RE
AWAITING OUR FINAL MEMBER WHO
IS SET TO LEAVE TESTIFYING
COMMITTEE SO- WE WILL GOING TO
RECESS UNTIL SHE'S ABLE TO
RETURN TO THE COMMITTEE SO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH IS
NOW IN RECESS.
OKAY SO AS
SENATOR MELINDA SETTLING DOWN I
WANT TO BE ABSOLUTELY SURE THAT
WE HAVE OUR TV ON SO- I AM NOW
GOING TO BRING THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH HEARING.
BACK. NOW PLEASE CONFIRM WITH
THE TV WE ARE ON BROADCAST
ABSOLUTELY SURE OKAY. ALL RIGHT
SO WITH THAT- WELCOME BACK WE
ARE NOW GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS
ON THE REMAINING BILLS SO WE'LL
BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN BY SOME
MEMBER SANTIAGO. AND WE HAVE
CONFIRMATION THAT'S BEING
BROADCAST RIGHT NOW. ALL RIGHT
OKAY- CONSULTANT PLEASE LET THE
CALL ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN MELINDA'S
VOTING. OKAY SO THAT BILL IS
OUT NINE ONE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
BY SUMMER SANTIAGO- CONSULT
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL MELINDA'S
NOW. ON THIS NOW THAT BILL IS
OUT NINE TWO. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY TWELVE
HUNDRED BY SOME MEMBER TEAM
CANCELED PLEASE CALL- CALL THE
UPS NUMBERS. MELINDA'S NOW
MELINDA SNOW. THAT BILL IS OUT
NINE TWO X. ITEMS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE BY SUMMER ROD REGUS
CONSULT PLEASE. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MELINDA'S. EXCEPT THOSE
OUT NINE ZERO FINALLY WE HAVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- WE HAVE
FIVE BILLS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AS PREVIOUSLY NOTED I
CANCELED PLEASE- LET'S CALL THE
OUTSIDE NUMBER MELINDA'S HI
MELINDA SAY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED ELEVEN
ZERO. OKAY WITH THAT THIS-
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
WEBSITE. POURED DIRECTLY TO OUR
COMMITTEE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IS PART OF THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION YEAH I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF WHO ARE
HERE- PRESENTS AND OTHER
TECHNICAL STAFF TO ENSURE THAT
THIS HEARING MOVE SMOOTHLY. WE
NOW CONSIDER AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH IS NOW
ADJOURNED. OKAY.